infowars reporter owen shroyer just
announced that the fbi has issued a
warrant for his arrest because
apparently he was standing on the steps
during the january 6 riots this is
interesting buzzfeed has a report on it
and apparently someone tipped off the
the feds and now he's got to turn
himself in on monday so we'll go through
that story
and uh at the same time we have a report
from the fbi basically debunking the
whole insurrection narrative they said
none of it was planned no coordination
trump did not coordinate or plan it yet
we still see what i think it's like 570
people have been arrested and charged
the charges are pretty intense
but uh we'll go through all that stuff
with that story and then we've got to
talk about these vaccine mandates in
australia they have imprisoned a man for
eight months because he was organizing a
protest it's draconian and it's here and
then we got new york and what new york
is doing is shocking the new york
mandate as you if for those of you that
have listened to this show for the past
week it's going to require businesses to
fire any employee with a with a
disability barring them from vaccination
this is a a shockingly draconian measure
so we're gonna we'll talk about all that
we're being joined by the mises guys
we've got dave's well do you guys want
to just introduce yourselves i'll just
throw it to you guys sure absolutely i'm
dave smith and this is the chair and
founder of the mises caucus the great
michael heiss
thanks for having me and i have to i
have to give a shout out i know he's not
here obviously but i gotta give a shout
out today is actually ron paul's 86th
birthday oh happy birthday
we're big fans we have his picture still
taped to the door i think don't we i
think so yeah i believe so so we on when
it was christmas luke came here
and he put ron paul on the top of our
tree because he's both a star and an
angel that's what it looks like
and then with the tree down luke just
taped ron paul to like one of the doors
in the house it's been there for almost
a year now yeah can i tell you man we're
fans happy birthday to the great ron
paul and what i love so much about ron
paul is just like you know you i know
you like to share and it is hilarious
and accurate but that meme of the
libertarian ideas and libertarian
candidates but then
even for all the people like all the the
right wingers who like will come on this
show and other shows and kind of you
know be like well the libertarians get
this wrong and they get this wrong and
then you're like okay now do ron paul
and you're like oh yeah you know what
that guy was right about everything he
was literally as we're in this country
that's on a suicide mission all the
things that are killing the country ron
paul was completely right about the wars
the debt the currency being destroyed
the the militarization of the police the
entire war on terrorism and also by the
way he was right about covid and the
lockdowns and all of that from day one
people were mocking him when he called
the whole thing a hoax and just an
excuse for government authoritarianism
you mean the lockdown zoaks the
lockdowns yes the whole the whole covid
regime this whole right justification
for like all of these draconian measures
to clarify for draconian youtube covet
is serious you're saying that covet is a
very nasty virus all of the government
responses have been horrendous and
stupid and done nothing to mitigate the
the virus but just to say that that is
basically what the mises caucus is about
is that we represent that wing of
libertarianism the ron paul
real libertarianism serious not
defending
dumb woke stuff not defending like silly
corporatism and stuff like that the real
tradition of mises rothbard and ron paul
you see jack dorsey tweeted rothbard i
sure did sure did tim what was that i
don't know i think he's just trying to
break my brain
anatomy of the state right
yeah that's the pamphlet uh which is by
the way go read anatomy of the state if
you haven't it's the it's the most
powerful 60 page essay pamphlet you'll
ever read in your life i thought that
was hilarious because all the
libertarians were tweeting like like a
nuke had dropped like
jack dorsey of twitter this like woke
just he just tweeted it and he just
tweeted it well from what i hear he's
like gotten real into bitcoin and stuff
and so maybe he's going down this rabbit
hole so jack if you're listening thank
you for tweeting that and stop kicking
people off your platform yeah he doesn't
own it anymore that's a problem he's
like uh six percent or two percent of
the company now so that's that's when
they start figuring out stuff he's an
example of a free market and cap uh
bitcoin enthusiasts technologists that
got co-opted by the corporate state
because they took it they took him they
paid a bunch of money then they took his
company they bought his company from him
now they use his face to try and sell
the brand well i i also wouldn't be
surprised i think they they basically
not so implicitly threatened
all of the big tech you know guys and
that's like the truth is that if you
look back at the the you know
social media scene in 2015 2016 as we
all remember it was the wild wild west
and i mean that as a libertarian as the
highest compliment yeah wild wild west
was the greatest time in the history of
the world um and so you you remember
there were people out there who would
just be like even really bad people who
you probably wouldn't want to hear from
but they were just out there advocating
their views no one was getting booted
off it was a completely free-for-all
free speech zone and then what happened
was you know donald trump won and the
corporate press needed some narrative as
to why this would happen it couldn't be
because hillary clinton was just such a
transparently awful person it had to be
because of fake news on social media and
they dragged him in front of congress
and basically
mafia style threatened all of them like
what are you going to do to crack down
on this fake news they had a huge
influence in creating this censorship
environment which is awful well we'll
get into all that stuff and uh you know
ian's chilling you've already heard from
him you know how it is
sup dudes in 2007 i remember obama and
ron paul very serious to me i took both
series but i was afraid ron paul was
going to be like darth vader i kept
getting this weird feeling like this is
darth if if he gets into office he's
going to be like darth vader and i don't
know what that meant but it was like he
was going to bring great balance to the
force and what did that mean in modern
day he probably would have repealed the
federal reserve act yeah i don't know
about that that would make him
upset our monetary system i i'd imagine
darth vader the one being proposing
right i'm the central bank for the for
the galactic empire i was afraid of him
and i was like obama's the hero i'm
going with obama
ron paul makes me afraid probably
because he would have he would have
ruptured this this crap system early
rather than let it get to where it's
gotten
i would imagine well
interesting but i think that's the myth
i mean the truth is that obama is really
the one i mean it's george w bush's
fault but obama bears so much of the
blame for ruining the country because
obama was the one who was voted in as a
counter to george w bush like the
country rejected george w bush so we
went okay we're going to go all the way
over with this very progressive
constitutional lawyer progressive named
barack hussein obama that's how much we
hate george w bush and he doubled down
on bush's policies brought the war in
afghanistan and iraq to libya somalia
pakistan yemen um and that really
coupled with the the record high
spending is what broke the whole system
so let's whatever fear you have of ron
paul obama is what left us with all of
this we'll get into all that we got
lydia pressing buttons i'm also sitting
in the corner i can already tell it's
going to be a great conversation i'm
delighted as ever to have dave smith
when i apologize i'm coming in hot it's
ron paul's birthday i'm not even letting
intros get out here
calm down we got this when um when jack
tweeted that i sent it immediately to to
dave and i was like oh my gosh look at
this what the heck's going on luke
tweeted i was like what the [ __ ] it's
happening that is that is how i saw it
is that you sent it to me and i went
that's got to be like a fake picture
right he got hacked
wait seriously yeah rothbard all right
everybody uh before we get started we
have a great sponsor we have biotrusts
ageless multi-collagen go to
strongerbonesandlife.com
and you can get 51 percent off of your
supply of ageless multi-collagen you
know how you do this stuff it's good for
your joints and your skin and your bones
and my friends i am an old man and i
have a half pipe and i skate all the
time i recently started wearing knee
pads for the first time in my life
because i kept falling and i was like
you know my knees hurt now that i'm old
not like an old man kind of hurt but i'm
like
i'm starting to feel something you know
on those knees i better start chugging
this ageless multi collagen from
biotrust so go to
strongerbonesnlife.com and you get a
60-day money-back guarantee the healthy
aging support of collagen in its ideal
forms five key types of collagen you
need from four different sources for
every order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
it is non-gmo free of artificial colors
flavors preservatives and sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
rbst nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth or other collagen supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
collagen supplements you get free
shipping with every order and here's the
best part free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust's team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order that that vip health
and fitness stuff i mean people get
healthy if there's one thing you can do
right now with all the craziness in the
world is start taking care of yourself
start there go for a walk if you go to
biotrust stronger bones in life.com they
support the show you can support them 51
off and you get that help check them out
so thank you to biotrust but don't
forget go to timcast.com become a member
and help support our fierce and
independent journalism you'll get an ad
free experience and access to all of our
members segments we've got a huge
library of members only podcasts from
this show there's a there's like a ton
we've like two episodes with alan west
we've got steve bannon really fun stuff
so become a member now let's jump in to
oh yeah smash the like button subscribe
to the channel we got to get through
these these intros let's talk about this
first story real quick just because this
one was kind of big when it when it
dropped only a couple hours ago buzzfeed
news reports infowars host owen shroyer
has been charged in the january six
riots
they say in a new complaint filed on
friday the u.s attorney's office in
washington charged troyer with illegally
going into a restricted area on the
capitol grounds and disorderly conduct
he's one of the highest profile
right-wing media personalities to be
prosecuted in connection with the
insurrection so far i love that buzzfeed
calls it an insurrection considering the
fbi just came out and said basically
wasn't but sure they mentioned that he's
based in texas he had been photographed
on a stage outside the capitol with alex
jones and the fbi said it received an
anonymous tip from someone noting other
video that appeared to show shroye at
the top of a set of stairs on the east
side of the capitol jones has not been
charged so this is what's what's
interesting right now i mean
it could potentially mean alex jones
there's a lot of higher profile people i
bet the fbi was waiting because if they
go for the really high profile people it
could be a shock to the system
so it looks like they're starting with
owen troyer i suppose and they may start
going for other people and he didn't
take any he didn't even take any selfies
i don't yeah in there no selfies you
know what's the point then you know
i don't know about you guys i don't want
to live in a society where just anyone
can walk up on some steps and not face
30 years in prison i mean come on we got
to clean this up 30 no i'm just i hope
not geez
that's uh
it is um it really is
it's no joke what the state will do when
they want to crack down on someone like
you know i was saying this um back uh
when they had that chazz
thing in seattle when they were playing
this little game and uh where they did
the little one in new york for a little
bit too and i was just saying i was like
listen you you lefties can have your fun
building your little thing and then
you'll probably abandon it in a few
weeks you know but don't get it twisted
if the government is letting you do this
because it's it suits their agenda right
now if they didn't want you to do this
they will waco you and lose no sleep
over it okay so that's what people need
to understand and that's i think what a
lot of people at january 6 did not
understand they thought ah this is funny
i'll go in here i'll fart on nancy
pelosi's desk or whatever now the people
calling in an insurrection are just this
is laughably stupid a coup attempt
laughably stupid um but
it is also really stupid to go in there
and think ha ha selfie while i'm farting
on nancy pelosi's desk like aha you're
going to do 40 years in prison now you
just you just went up and slapped in the
face the most powerful government in
human history what do you think they do
to people like why do you what do you
think they'll do this to everyone in the
middle east but they won't mess with you
that's why it's important to understand
what the nature of government is exactly
like it's not just some service provider
that we like change the clothes on and
you might get some left-wing service
providing over here and some right-wing
cert it's it's force well that's exactly
right michael's exactly right they had
this mythology of like well what this is
the people's house like i was saying
before no it's not it's the war
criminals house this house don't belong
to you and this isn't even like a like a
fringe concept this is george washington
george washington said the government
was forced this is this is uh there's
something uh what was i saying earlier
i'm saying something like
the the way they view this country i was
talking about afghanistan the way that
the establishment views this country is
not as a nation on founding principles
of life liberty pursuit of happiness and
a bill of rights it's this is where we
can test weapons and then run our
companies to go and extort other
countries and invade and so we as
americans
a lot
and even many like traditional democrats
i don't know about today it's getting
kind of crazy out there but up on like
when when the afghan war started you had
democrats and republicans
who mostly view this country as the
history of the founding fathers and
world war ii and civil rights but the
people running these companies they
don't see this country that way they
don't know they don't care they're like
this is just our hub for militarism and
then they they run their companies here
and they go to other places and do their
thing but there's something interesting
in that uh you know just downstairs we
were talking i've got these these utah
gold back things i bought off the
internet yeah they're like it's like a
gold foil you know one one thousandth of
an ounce
and uh one of one of our friends
mentioned that the constitution says
that gold and silver are the only
currency is that is that true yes yes
they've never amended that yes and also
that the that states can um make legal
tender that is gold and silver but
nothing else but yes that's right that's
pretty sure it defines it as an actual
measure of a certain amount of grains of
gold well i don't know if that's
actually in the constitution but that
was common parlance at the time was that
yes that's what a dollar meant um but
yeah the constitution absolutely defines
legal tender as gold and silver and that
ever changed oh yeah article 1 section
10 no state shall coin money emit bills
of credit make anything but gold and
silver a tender in payment of debts
that means that the only
constitutionally valid uh forms of money
are gold and silver oh they're debunking
it they're saying it's a myth
anything that restrains government is a
myth
yeah i mean look there's certainly i'm
sure like with everything in the
constitution there'll be people who
interpret it in different ways um but
look richard nixon when he took us off
the gold standard in 71 he said it was a
temporary measure he said he had
temporarily closed the convertibility
from dollars into gold which was the
ultimate default and violation of a
contractual agreement between the world
i mean that we were on we were on an
agreement in the bretton woods agreement
that dollars were
essentially notes they still say notes
on them that they were notes that you
were represented you were holding gold
and just like most temporary government
programs it's uh should end any day now
do you want to break down the bretton
woods agreement what that was sure so
the well the bretton woods agreement was
wreck coming out of world war ii
basically all the other industrial
powers had been destroyed and and the
united states had the vast majority of
the gold reserves and so we basically
made a deal with the rest of the nations
that if they took our dollars as their
reserve currency then we would we would
back our dollars up by gold at 35 an
ounce and so basically they were on a
gold standard because they were on a
dollar standard and then in the 60s uh
we really started cheating you know we
fought the war in vietnam we put a man
on the moon we launched the entitlement
state we were spending like crazy and
they called our bluff and they said okay
no i don't think you have this much gold
we're going to turn in our dollars for
gold and then nixon started
we're still spending the credit for the
convertibility uh because they called
our bluff because we cheated we were
acting like a bank yes exactly like the
worst type of bank right like a reckless
bank didn't actually have the money and
then you know it's funny because then we
go off the gold standard in in 1971 and
it's officially fiat currency bill even
though like i said we were cheating
already in the 60s right but we go off
the gold standard in the early 70s and
sometimes even really good progressives
like bernie sanders well you know
and good progressives will say things
or they'll be like you know like the the
average wages have been so stagnant
since right about the 70s and the rich
have been getting so much richer since
right about the 70s you know the cost of
everything has gotten out of control
since right about the 70s and you know
what happened
greed
you know like they never have an answer
for for what it is but what happened is
that we removed any restraints from the
government to print as much money as
they want and this is where you've seen
the true rise of gigantic government
endless wars
corporate bailouts and also wall street
that wall street was not a place where
people were making insane amounts of
money like this like at least on the
level since then that really started in
the 80s the gordon gecko generation this
is what happened when you had this funny
money that people can just play and
speculate well so let's let's rope this
back to yes what the government is so
you know we're talking about owen
schroeder january 6 and the potential
that the government might go after
people but we also have this story from
reuters fbi finds scant evidence of u.s
capital attack was coordinated so they
basically go through it and they say
nobody
they say it was not centrally
coordinated by far-right groups
prominent supporters of trump according
to their sources were either directly
involved or briefed regularly on the
wide-ranging investigations
i got a text message
from someone running against lauren
bobert
and what do you think
they they told me they were for as to
why i should give them money
i got a text i just said hey my name is
so-and-so and this is why you should
vote for me like they didn't say like
that like a personal text message like a
mass text message i mean it's like it's
a campaign text message right no but i'm
saying not like someone knew you on the
campaign right right okay so they got my
number from a registry or something they
are running against lauren bobert and
what do you think they're that they
thought to themselves i have one text
message to send this guy
here's what i need to say to get him to
give me money what do you think that one
thing was i really hope it was getting
back on the gold standard but i know
that's not going to be stopping lauren
bobert yes
uh marjorie taylor green's accomplice
lauren bobert is is being char is being
investigated and we're gonna stop her
and i'm like you're not for anything
yeah what is this i was like you you
want me to donate because you don't like
lauren bobert that's not that's not
something to vote for
and so i bring that up because what
they've been doing with the media and
the democrats with january 6 is trying
to create some reason you'd vote for
them
negative partisanship they don't really
have anything that's like if there's a
flood and everyone's trying to find a
leader to help us through this this
great flood that's destroyed so much
land and people are running they're like
vote for me because i hate floods floods
are bad no i'm going to stop the floods
it's worse than me like come on it's
worse than god's give me something
there's
there's a flood and there's a boating
company and the guy says vote for me
because that boating guy it's his fault
i hate him yeah and you're like what do
you do about the flood hey hey hey we're
dealing with hating right now well right
well part of it i think a huge part of
it is that what can they really say
you know what what could this is why you
know hillary clinton's entire campaign
against donald trump was look how awful
donald trump is because what else could
she say i mean could she sit there to
the american people and say well look i
gave you guys a rack i mean i gave you
guys libya i gave you guys banker
bailouts i mean what are you not happy
with right so they knew trump only
exists because people were so furious
about what they had been given by the
clintons in the bushes and obama right
so they can't so the only play they have
is to tell you that this
like um uprising against the
establishment is so ugly and awful look
the worst thing ever is january 6th not
the country being completely sold out by
the ruling elite that's not the pro the
problem is the people furious about it
and okay sure they might be furious
about a thing that isn't exactly the
right thing to be furious about like i
don't know if then what happened in the
election i my base assumption is all
elections are fraudulent but i don't
know what happened in the 2020 election
but
if if you
just look in general why they got to
this level of anger it wasn't just one
election it was a series of events you
know that led to this i i think obama
yeah i remember 2008 i remember seeing
all of my friends
screaming and foam coming out of their
mouths obama i was in chicago and i went
down to millennium park or grand park
whatever they called i don't know the
big park and they had this big screen
and obama's speaking and everyone's
screaming and cheering there are people
everywhere and they were like bush was
nuts he wasn't our president it was a
victory through the supreme court we
were upset about it finally all of these
wars are going to end this was a mistake
we shouldn't have gotten in these wars
it's all over and then obama goes
um gonna bomb a pakistani village and
that was like one of the first orders he
gave was the bom and then i remember
seeing that and i was just like
oh here we go i guess yeah that was like
that i don't remember how old that was i
wasn't that old and i was just kind of
like getting whacked in the face because
i was like when i was a teenager i was
hanging out with all these punk
anarchist types who are like the system
is broken it can never be fixed and then
i was like yeah and then i got older and
i'm like hey you look obama you know
he's doing something like this is going
to be the chance to like have some
normalcy and then he's just like oh i'm
going to drop some bumps yeah and then
he did and then i was like these people
are just all lying yeah he actually
doubled down on the worst of the bush
policies yeah yeah he expanded the war
in the middle east he expanded it in the
middle east expanded the the not only
the wars um uh
drastically and then also expanded the
entire national security apparatus
created the spy you know we were upset
during bush about like warrantless
wiretapping and obama was like hold my
beer i'm collecting every piece of
metadata on every american citizen and i
just by every metric by the the spending
the wars then everything the extra
judicial assassinations of american
citizens yeah and and there was
something even more devastating about it
coming from the guy who was the reaction
to bush i mean this is why after obama
you get trump because you have bush who
everyone rejects then the reaction
against bush within the system everyone
rejects two for for being on the same
page as bush and then you're like well
where do we go from here and they're
telling you your options are jeb bush or
hillary clinton and then they heard the
most powerful campaign statement ever
when donald trump was on that debate
stage and
it was megan kelly and she said you've
called women fat pigs and he went only
rosie o'donnell and then everybody
started cheering and screaming and i am
joking but there was something to that
oh it was very powerful he had he had
several that were very powerful and the
reason why that one was so powerful is
because he just went i'm not playing
your game
yeah circumvented the whole thing that's
right and and what's
you know you touched on that politics is
about being against the other what's
scary about that is how pervasive it is
because you know you look at approval
ratings for the media super low approval
ratings for politicians super low and
then people still keep putting the
incumbents back in it's like how do you
account for that how do you break that
cycle because obviously the hate for the
other is stronger than the disapproval
for the status quo it's like how do you
deal with that yeah do you guys see that
trans anarchist satanist who won the
primary for the republicans up in new
hampshire
no and i usually keep up with trans i
know
uh arya i think her name is yeah yeah
yeah and uh uh it was a point that
people just go in and hit r they would
walk in and go republican republic i
don't care who and so you gotta know who
you're voting for don't vote for someone
if you don't know who they are you can
vote for the person you do like people
peop you know we talked about on the
show getting rid of the party
affiliation on ballots
because then people would be like
i don't know
and that's prob random is probably
better than tribal party line or another
one they could adopt what we do in the
libertarian party which is on every
single election there is none of the
above is an option
that would be nice so
so the the seat could be vacant
yeah yeah it could be it could be vacant
or um if there was nobody else running
basically somebody we nominate x you
know and you just kind of take it from
the floor i would i would love to end up
with just like president jimmy just like
some dude in the crowd like yeah no and
how about this dude and like he just
gives it a whirl well do you know what
denmark is
rule by ra rule at random rule at random
yeah so i i remember at an anarchist
friend we were talking a lot about how
this would work and like what it would
be and the idea would be you'd get like
congress duty you'd be like you'd come
home from work you're all tired and you
grab the mail and you go inside and you
throw it down and then you see like
official notice and you're like oh what
is this and you open it's like you have
been randomly selected for congress duty
you must report to dc here's your
stipend you're like
honey i got congress duty
honey can you make dinner tonight i'm a
senator
all right
i'll be home in six years
well no no but it'll be for like two
months oh okay yeah be like probably the
same thing like jury duty they'll be
like like they would just go to whoever
is like controlling them and be like i'm
absolutely a racist
you don't want me it'd be the same as
jury duty where you just don't respond
and hope that they never enforce that
i'm just kidding i don't know but
jury duties different from congress duty
congress duty is like you're an american
with opinions yeah so you know you're
here it would it would be like you're
here for six months
you know here's quick orientation and
the idea is that a random person with a
short term who's not going to profit off
it doesn't want to be the person walking
out being like i didn't start the war it
wasn't me like yeah i mean look it's
it's kind of a fun idea to play with but
i wouldn't really want to be governed
that way how about we just tremendously
reduce if not eliminate the role of the
federal government and let people be
free you don't want to just pick random
people who know nothing about politics
or governing or anything what have them
you know what about vacancies like what
if you could on a ballot it would be
like jane doe john smith and no one vape
like elect a vacant seat and you could
be like i don't want anybody going to dc
on my name all right that i am all for
and that's just like congress has just
like less people there
i think you could get a populist
movement behind that to be honest yeah
just no one in congress yes it's just
the worst but the problem then is uh
it's it you know the reason it wouldn't
work is because other people would be
like now's our chance and then with
democrats being like if you do this and
the republicans have a majority and if
there's no one in congress then the
president is unrestrained so i gotta
admit i think the system devised by the
founding fathers is absolutely brilliant
when you look at other countries
especially three branches doing
different different kind of things the
problem is there was this conspiracy on
jekyll island
the federal reserve emerged and all of a
sudden nothing mattered anymore well
there's that but there's also the
arguments people forget that there was a
big argument as to whether or not we
should even have a constitution and and
the anti-federalists the people who are
arguing against the constitution
pretty prescient like they they've been
i mean their arguments they said that
this is going to become a king and
through executive order that is what has
happened one of the problems uh if you
study shea's rebellion which was after
the revolutionary war these this the
foreign powers wanted to get their debt
back from the americans for the war debt
and but they didn't they wanted hard
currency they wanted metal and gems they
didn't want paper currency the farmers
only made their money by bartering their
food they didn't have anything so they
normally paid their debts with by
printing paper and sending it off the
merchants that own this basically
controlled the state legislature were
like we need hard currency from these
farmers because we need to pay our
foreign debts farmers like we don't have
it so they started putting people in
debtors prison the farmers basically
started going to the courthouses and
standing outside with weapons blocking
the the judges from from adjudicating
uh so they couldn't be thrown in
debtor's prison and it caused massive
chaos the state couldn't get its local
people to fight to stop it so they had
to send in state troops and they
realized that
without a constitution without a
centralized authority on taxes each
state would tax their own people
individually and has the potential to
cause massive chaos and disruption so
it's better to have one authority
controlling all the tax money well i
mean if your concern is debtor's prison
i mean we still have debtors prison it's
just the irs now that's enforcing it i
mean people do go to jail for not paying
their taxes that is nothing more than a
debt people also go to jail by the way
for not paying child support i mean
there still are forms of debtors present
i will say though i think a lot of
people overhype the irs
like the irs isn't going to lock you up
if you owe money well that's true but
they'll ruin you
but i mean
so i know people who have run a follow
the irs with their businesses to large
sums of money and
a guy showed up and said look here's
what happened with your business and the
guy was like uh i'm broke and they were
like what can you do and he's like i
mean my shop's going under we have no
money and they were like all right well
we'll we'll we'll circle back in a few
months see where you're at and maybe
there's something you can do it's like
the irs said you should be like cuff
them boys well no that's true i i know
that there's yeah but i also know people
whose businesses have been destroyed by
the irs who have gotten like 20 years
yeah i mean like it's like so that
that's not nothing i mean look
destroying someone's business as we've
learned in the lockdowns that's not a
small thing no these are the type of
things that break up families that lead
to suicides that lead to children being
scarred i mean it's a very serious thing
and you're right i mean yes there's not
like a massive amount of people in jail
for not paying their taxes but if we
want to really figure out this
experiment we could make all taxes
voluntary tomorrow and then we would
really find out how many people pay them
because they're scared of the threat of
jail time and how many people don't pay
them because they don't and that's yeah
then we can figure it out so so if it
would be zero then what you're conceding
is that the reason people pay it is
because they're scared of the threat of
of jail time bro bro listen listen
there's a socialist magazine just fired
all its staff because they were trying
to form a union
yeah god i love it we we're the young
turks the story came out last year jank
yuger was trying to union-bust or
whatever was yelling at people you've
got that that bernie sanders supporting
woman actually she's right on your
nicolo she bought a million dollar condo
oh yeah yeah i'm i'm not i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna drag the success of these
individuals who are progressive but at
the same time i'll tell you this i'd be
willing to bet those people would not
pay taxes if they were given the choice
yeah and then and they would say
something like well this is this is the
system we're in and i'm just
you know living the way it's supposed to
be and the fact that they can find a
rationalization in their mind to be
whatever i saw one of them where he's
like wearing his like you know like eat
the rich shirt or something like that
and then they show his house oh that was
a song today yeah like uh you know i
mean it's just like come on the idea
that you can justify that hypocrisy
again like you i don't hate any of their
success i actually admire it um i don't
agree with their politics but i admire
people who succeed in life and we should
all be inspired by that and learn from
that hassan streams like 10 hours a day
yeah and and so he's i i looked at his
numbers and i'm like i think he's
probably making three four mil i could
be wrong just an estimate and i got mad
respect for that hustle yeah sure and i
also
don't mind someone being a progressive
and believing in higher taxes and a
welfare state and all that stuff and
being rich so but the funny thing about
the hassan situation for those that are
familiar he's like the biggest political
streamer on the left probably he bought
a three million dollar house he's
getting roasted by socialists
conservative so breitbart wrote an
article and they were like
you know socialist streamer buys three
million dollar house and i'm like
i mean that's a great story i guess i
don't see the criticism i don't know why
i'd care he's not like advocating for
people not have houses or not be rich
he's just very much for heavy taxation
and i'm sure he's paying 50 to 60 in
taxes but the socialists are pissed off
are they threatening to eat him
um they they there's a they're getting
their their bibs on and their forks and
they're like
no no they they're defending him saying
that like there's a big difference
between jeff bezos and hassan and all
that stuff and
i that's i get it i'm not going to straw
man their argument like there's a big
difference between jeff bezos sure and a
guy on twitch yeah i mean i okay fine
but you know
if you really have some perspective on
on the issue to be someone who you know
if you're worth 10 million dollars let's
just say for the sake of argument for
this guy which he's probably at least
got a net worth of that much right let's
say his net worth is 10 million if you
have a net worth of 10 million dollars
in 2021 in a first world country
compared to all of the human beings who
have ever existed
throughout history you are a level of
rich that is
could would be
magic
to
99.99 of human beings who have ever
existed just couldn't even conceive
kings would have no like no concept of
the wealth that you have so to say oh
well i can compare him to jeff bezos and
he's not as rich as that guy i mean like
have some perspective you're talking
about the rich you are amongst the most
wealthy privileged human beings who have
ever existed in this like meaty flesh
balls circling around the sun that we
live on we went to a mall like two weeks
ago
and they have in when you walk in the
center is this like you know 200 foot
tall dome with you know this is this
beautiful glass and architecture and i
looked at it and i was like
if a king from like the medieval world
saw this he would say for what god was
this built and we'd be like i'm just
getting a mochaccino dude i don't i
don't know about no gods dude if you
could be a king in like the 1400s or be
you in this house right now i bet you
would choose being you i got a toilet
dude yeah
if you get a headache you got some advil
somewhere i bet if you want to go
downstairs watch something you go
downstairs you turn on the big screen tv
if you were king you have to go
downstairs and have some dude like tell
stories for you and then the stories
might suck and you got to kill that dude
and find a new dude to tell you
if you want to eat ice cream they'd have
to bring the the the ice block covered
in sawdust
and then walk it up and grab the salt
and put it in the bowl with the cream
and then like use the salt ice and
you're sitting there being like i'm
going to have ice cream soon and then
it's just like bland sweet like not
sweet
we've got it's brutal we got ice cream
downstairs it's made from fungus that
they took this they genetically modified
a fungus to make whey protein and it
legit just tastes like regular ice cream
but it's made from fungus
kings would not fathom a creation of
such that's right and it's so [ __ ]
back then too they don't talk about it a
lot because they were all it was
desensitized to the stink but like if
you go to viet the vietnam soldiers came
back from vietnam they're like the thing
you notice the most is how bad it stinks
in vietnam it's hot like hot and it
stinks the point that you're touching on
though is that and and i agree is that
fundamentally there is a difference
between like a self-made millionaire
that worked you know pulled themselves
up from their boobs strats and and the
corporatists the problem is and i know
this doesn't apply to like jimmy dore
and like the the better half of the
progressives but the left has become
corporatists and that has been made very
clear with these bailouts or not i'm
sorry not the balance the lockdowns
because
you know who made out on that and who's
who's morally in support of the
lockdowns the left
this is my thing with like the hassan
buying the big house i'm like i'm i'm
glad he got a big house i think that's
fantastic and you know the socialists
who are criticizing or criticizing for
the wrong reasons criticize the dude
because
he's an authoritarian you know he's pro
government mandate yeah criticize what's
wrong with his his policies now i think
it's fair to criticize the hypocrisy of
people saying like the rich need to pay
their fair share and it's so unfair that
some people have so much and some people
have so little if you're gonna argue
like that if you're gonna argue that
employers should be paying their their
employees a higher wage well look if
like here's my thing right if you're if
you're saying
inequality is a moral outrage and you
have a net worth of 10 million dollars
well you can
do something right now in the world for
inequality by sharing a whole bunch of
your money with other people and so if
you don't i do think there's a level of
hypocrisy that can be criticized for
keeping all of this for yourself living
this very comfortable life and then
complaining that others don't share
their wealth let's break this down real
quick
as to what we're seeing
hassan [ __ ] works really really hard
and through his talent and his drive and
his passion he has become extremely
successful and made a lot of money
to him he's like i know i'm rich but the
real problem is that guy right below him
are the socialists saying you know look
we're not
wealthy we're middle class but that guy
and they're pointing at hassan so what
happens you have this scale where the
poor person with nothing is pointing to
the middle class saying these people
don't understand what they have the
middle class people are pointing at
hassan saying oh he's exploiting he
doesn't understand what he has then
people like ethan klein and his son are
pointing at bezos being like they're the
real problem the point is no matter
where you are at they're always pointing
at someone who's wealthier than they are
saying they're the problem and someone
in sub-saharan africa is like you're all
the problem
i have nothing it's it's the folly of
the anti-capitalistic mentality yeah you
know well that's right and i think to
the point michael was making before that
there is something that
and one of the worst parts i think about
the the last 20 years particularly but
really i guess you could say since
jekyll island but is that
we
um
we have this crony corrupt system that
we call capitalism
and so of course
people reject this because they do know
on some level that this is unfair and it
is unfair because the whole system is
completely rigged by the powerful and of
course that's true but it's rigged
through
primarily government policies bought and
paid for politicians regulatory capture
a whole series like an entire system
that rigs the game and what michael i
think was saying is that there is a
difference somebody who is just
successful in the market who has nothing
to do with government connections they
are whether you like the product that
they're selling or not the people buying
it do that's why they're buying it they
have made their wealth because they
provide a product that people want more
than their money and so they're willing
to voluntarily give their money up for
that product the people who make their
money because they have some type of
government connection some type of
regulatory capture some type of bought
off politician they make their money
because people are forced to pay them
for their product and that is unfair and
in the same sense that we bomb iraq and
call it operation iraqi freedom well i
wonder why no iraqi is going to want to
buy freedom anymore after that right the
left has gotten away with calling
corporatism or economic fascism
capitalism for far too long and if they
just dropped that they would find out
that we're against it too
there's a great example uh
candace owens tweeted
blackrock is buying up houses and
they're getting money from the
government this is communism and then on
reddit a bunch of progressives posted
that and saying literally capitalism and
i'm like yo you're both wrong
the point pointing at the communists and
being like the government giving private
institutions free money to manipulate
and control the system is not communism
and it's not capitalism it's fascism
well and you can see where they each
have enough of a rationalization to sell
it amongst their base right because so
so if you just looked at the american
system today it's like okay well sean
hannity can sell to his base that this
is socialism because look how big the
government is and look at the deficit
and look at all of this right and look
at the government and involvement right
so he can sell this as socialism and
then of course um you know whoever msnbc
equivalent of that you know rachel
maddow can sell it as this is capitalism
because look at the corporate profits
and look at it all right so they they
each have enough but what we really
objectively if you look at the whole
picture here this is not a battle
between the idea that there's a battle
between big government and big business
at this time like okay like we our
government is what are they gonna spend
seven trillion dollars this year they're
the biggest government that's ever
existed in human history and look at the
size of big corporations they're bigger
than ever okay so clearly big business
loves big government and big government
loves big business this is one
conglomerate at this point and what do
you call that because there is a term
for it and it's not socialism or
capitalism that's fascism dave
economically i know i want to see
fascism the irs the international
internal revenue service been around
since the 1862 looks like uh what's his
name abe lincoln created it probably to
fund the war fascist in 1914 there was
like a revolution within the internal
revenue service oddly right after they
formed the federal reserve 1914 or right
then when they were forming it and they
created the new income tax
you guys know i would love to hear from
you guys about the history of the irs
yeah so well well the income tax so all
of this stuff right was under the
woodrow wilson administration and yes
it's certainly not a coincidence right
that right after the year after they
created the federal reserve well then
it's like okay well if this fed's going
to lend us our own money that we will
now owe them back with interest well
we're going to need a little bit of a uh
of
a stream of money coming in and the way
the income tax was sold uh was that it
was only going to uh apply to the top
top one percent of people they sold this
as a this was during the progressive era
as it was known and they sold this as a
progressive measure so this is don't
even work listen this is going to be
something that's going to be for the fat
cats the robber barons it's going to be
like 2 of their income like we're going
to take that and then we'll share it
around with everybody and the rest of us
will all be wealthier this is not going
to apply to your average working joe of
course
they won't stop saying the same thing
over and over again they're still to
this day they still use the same but at
the time it was like okay so that's how
they got the support and that's how they
got so we got the federal reserve in
play we got uh the income tax in play
and three years later we're in a world
war
i mean you know what federal reserve
really is doing it's just their legal
way of reaching into your bank account
and taking your money that's right
that's all they do right so as the great
ron paul happy birthday again used to
always say right the the real tax is
spending the real tax is government
spending because when government spends
money what can they do well all they can
do is they can either tax the money from
you
or they can borrow the money which is a
promise to tax you in the future or they
can print the money which is in effect
just taxing you right now or a little
bit in the future because it's just
robbing the value of your dollar so when
government spends a dollar they've
stolen a dollar from you forget taxation
is theft government spending is theft
and the reason the like so when we got
into world war one was it 1917 we got
into world war one okay so just a few
years after this then well i know the
plan for the income tax was just to be
for the top one percent and you weren't
gonna but crisis
world war
so now everybody's gonna have to pay
taxes and we're gonna have to increase
the rates and then you know the the
crisis will be over soon except then we
have a great depression that's another
crisis we have the second world war
that's another crisis and then oh by the
way this is just permanent government
policy
there is a there is a fee for producing
something that you are now not only is
there a fee for you having a job and
being a productive member of society but
you lose any semblance of fifth
amendment rights to not incriminate
yourself you now have to incriminate
yourself every year to the federal
government because you are already
presumed guilty presumed a criminal by
your own government for the crime of
being a productive member of society
yeah and and what's funny about that is
they're supposed to issue a receipt on
what your taxes go for and of course you
know you're under penalty if you don't
comply and there's absolutely no
accountability for them if they don't so
and what you were saying as far as
income taxes were never supposed to be
for the average wage earner you know and
then you also pointed out earlier um
the the
suspending of gold was supposed to be
temporary it's just that it's that
classic uh harry brown quote if there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
uh government program yeah so let them
have a little power they're not giving
it back easy what ends up happening when
they start this is it's just for the
rich it's no big deal it won't affect
you well it's an emergency so everyone's
going to pitch in
then it's well the emergency we got
another emergency well now it's another
world war and then by the time it's the
crisis are finally calming down and you
come out and say okay you're appealing
this they'll be appealing what well the
taxes what do you mean the taxes have
always been there well right exactly
nobody's got a problem with anything
think about euro far right right so 10
years ago nine years ago we killed osama
bin laden just just now we're pulling
out of the war in afghanistan so is it
like okay well goodbye tsa
no tsa ain't going nowhere man that's
the norm now you're used to that don't
ever believe the the the lesson here is
don't ever believe there are 15 days to
flatten the curve on anything because
it's never that it's never temporary
yeah afghanistan was another one it was
never supposed to be this
broad war on terrorism or this 20-year
thing oh yeah supposed to be to go and
get the terrorists that knocked down the
twin towers if you look at the auma i
mean the language of it uh was oh just
to go get the people who knocked down
the twin towers what's that that was the
the authorization oh i'm sorry yes
mf the authorization of uh military
force so they didn't authorization
authorization yeah they didn't declare
war they they declared uh military force
for a constrained mission which was to
go get bin laden in the terrorists and
that's why you know ron paul actually
voted for that because that what is what
is what it was supposed to be and then
he he also tried to issue letters of
marquee and reprisal to basically hire
mercenaries to to help get these named
people bin laden his lieutenants but you
know and that didn't happen and then
they they took that inch and ran about
40 50 miles with it 20 years with it
yeah and it should be uh like noted that
look they had osama bin laden in i think
even their november december of 2001
when they had him pinned in tora bora
and they could have killed osama bin
laden and they they had forces over in
kabul fighting the taliban they had
forces in the north green berets in the
north that they didn't even call into
the action the forces on the ground were
saying we need reinforcements right here
we've got osama bin laden we could have
killed osama bin laden in late 2001 been
done with the whole thing called off the
entire terror war and man what a better
world we're living in if that's what we
do and instead they allowed
whether intentionally or unintentionally
and i really i'm just speculating but i
lean toward intentionally on this they
allowed him to escape into pakistan
because i'll tell you
look
there's no question that the the a lot
of the people the forces on the ground
were like there's no we can block off
the [ __ ]
the pakistan border right now and we can
get bin laden this is easy if you just
send us the reinforcements and they had
specifically the bush administration had
not declared war on al qaeda they had
not declared war on the people who did
911 they had not even declared war on
afghanistan they declared war on
terrorism on terror and they had already
had plans to go into iraq on the
pretense that he was working with osama
bin laden now if you kill osama bin
laden in december 2001
what really is the motivation to go into
iraq and all of these other wars you
probably lose it but if he's still out
there and he could be working with other
people and he could be plotting these
things then you've got 20 years of war
you think if hillary would have won we'd
be in iran
i don't know um i think certainly it it
you wouldn't have had the deal the the
uh or i'm sorry if hillary had one i'm
thinking 2008 you're thinking you're
talking 2016. right so if hillary had
one in 2016 i
i think it's likely she would have
wanted to push for it the problem with
the warren in iran is that no matter how
many of the um blood-soaked monster
neocons and i include hillary clinton in
that list want a war with iran the
actual logistics of doing it are so bad
that many people in the military are
like look we just can't do a war with
iran because iran is a more serious
adversary than any of the countries
we've picked on in the middle east right
now they will they will slaughter uh u.s
military members all around i want to i
want to show people something real quick
we have this map so you can understand a
lot of people don't know the geography
iraq is just to the west of iran and
afghanistan is to the east i don't
believe it was a coincidence we said
iraq and afghanistan what was in the
middle and what did john bolton say he
wanted to do he said this time next year
we will be celebrating victory in tehran
yeah we had a pincer attack on iran but
iran is not iraq or afghanistan it is a
mountainous very well populated armed
strong nation yeah but they've wanted to
go after iran for a long time oh no
question did you ever see that video
from i think it was around two thousand
three five you know fact checked me on
that but of uh general wesley clark
where he was saying
prior to uh them going into iraq they
were telling him we're going into iraq
and then the plan after that is to go
into venezuela and ultimately iran and
he named like four or five countries
seven countries he also included syria
in that list i think sudan was in the
list as well yeah no it didn't play out
exactly like the plan that he mentioned
but there was certainly something to
that and you watch that what real what
did happen after uh 9 11 was wars all
throughout the middle east i mean wars
in you know iraq afghanistan somalia
pakistan libya
yeah well they they yeah but not a you
know not a war like we had in these
countries central banks and all these
countries
they want to get in there install the
central banking system get out and then
we won we've unified the world through
economics which goes back to what we
were talking about before is that one of
the primary weapon here is debt
like like students debt businesses with
the lockdowns debt you know credit card
debt like everything is debt and and
they're getting us to keep feeding them
with our productivity by
ensnaring us in debt yeah for sure
and that's i'll just say and don't buy
listen don't buy their propaganda about
this whole thing in afghanistan and i
hope that people can can see through it
like i'm not saying this isn't kind of
ugly joe biden's pull you know
withdrawal from afghanistan and that
there's not some like ugly aspects of it
but just like take a step back zoom out
and peep game you know what i mean like
see what's going on here when cnn
is saying this is a nightmare oh this is
a tragedy joe biden oh what if what has
he done i'm kind of like wait a minute
but here's what drives me crazy right is
that i see these people like like right
winger types who like i agree with on
some stuff not on others but i see i see
uh charlie curt tweeted something i
think it was him he tweeted something
where he goes you know cnn saying
something and they go
he takes it as a dig on biden he goes
man when you've lost cnn you're really
doing bad it's like no charlie kirk you
got this game all wrong man why did he
lose cnn because he ended a freaking war
that's why he lost cnn did obama lose
cnn when he destroyed libya oh no that
wasn't a problem see all of a sudden the
corporate press has these these deep
passionate humanitarian impulses all of
a sudden there's this moral outrage
about the innocent people in afghanistan
we have we have started wars in about
six or seven different countries that
have led to millions of innocent people
being slaughtered not a peep out of the
corporate press not a peep as in yemen
babies
are vomiting to death
by the hundreds of thousands because of
the u.s
saudi war in yemen not a peep out of the
corporate press but all of a sudden
they're the humanitarians the one time
we end the war and when was the other
time they became big humanitarians when
donald trump tried to end the war in
syria who the kurds what about the kurds
see through this man do you remember
what the media said when trump fired 59
tomahawk missiles into syria it's
presidential exactly beautiful is this
the time trump has become a president
that's right so so don't they don't
cheer the assassination of salamani
that's right don't it maybe it's just a
wild coincidence that every time it's
within the military industrial complexes
interests the corporate press becomes
humanitarian and when it's in their
interests they look the other way and
don't care so that's all i'm saying
listen by the way for anyone out there
joe biden is the architect uh the
architect architect of some of the worst
policies in modern american history he
is an evil person and he is very
responsible directly for the war on
terrorism particularly the war in iraq
under george w bush that he championed
and voted for okay and he's also just an
embarrassing
like elderly you know incompetent person
but
this is this is not what it appears to
be you were saying something before the
show about you know if you know when we
plot of a war they're going to make sure
it's bad like yeah that people are in
the future they're going to be like well
if we do pull our troops out of iraq i
mean remember what happened in
afghanistan oh you know we don't know
and so i i was thinking about this
people need to understand
it's only been a couple presidents
george w bush starts a war obama takes
it runs with it trump says i'm ending
this
biden then says i'm going to follow
through which is a good thing but
i i 100 believe if donald trump kept
troops at 15 500
joe biden wouldn't be talking about it
at all it's because trump was drawing
down the troops and they were freaking
out and then biden comes in and he's
like how do we get more troops in so pay
attention now because we can sit here
and be like it's a good thing he's
ending this war but they're sending more
troops in already well here's the thing
i really do believe and and i had that
attitude too when when biden first
pushed back the the date because donald
trump organized uh he organized a
ceasefire with the taliban negotiated a
ceasefire and a withdrawal date which
was in march i believe it was early in
march of of this year biden came in and
said it was supposed to be may 1st i'm
sorry i'm sorry that's right it was may
1st biden came in and pushed it back to
september 11th i think
at the time i thought he was just
bailing on the whole thing i was like
he's not going to pull out at all um but
then i guess it was just for political
reasons to be like well we can't i can't
just say i did trump's thing i have to
do it my own way and make it more you
know like on a an important day
september 11th um but the reality of the
situation is that with the troop levels
that we had in under under trump and
even with these troops that biden sent
in to kind of help with the evacuation
process the the thing is this right
a lot of people and a lot of people in
the corporate press they kind of create
this false narrative where they say well
i mean maybe we could just leave the
troops in there now at that like the
level we have now and it wouldn't be
this this unstable and made and look
there hasn't really been an american
casualty there for like the last couple
years but what they don't acknowledge is
that the reason there hasn't been an
american casualty the reason things have
been stable is because donald trump
negotiated a ceasefire contingent on us
leaving if biden were to say we're not
leaving now and stay in at this point
the taliban runs that country we will
need listen we couldn't beat him with
well over a hundred thousand troops that
barack obama had there so if we want to
go back to this war now it will be a
bloodbath unless we're willing to send
in another hundred thousand troops in
which case we will drive the guerrilla
talibans back out into the mountains
they'll sit there for another decade
we'll draw down and they'll come back
and take over again
so what do you want to do guys so i
think that just out of practicality i
think this war is over i don't think
they i don't think there's any thing
they could do that's not going to be a
worst disaster at this point and there's
just no public appetite for it i don't
think anymore you know i i do in the
midst of that though i do want to kind
of draw a distinction between the ending
of a war and the withdrawing of troops
because even as the troops were being
withdrawn under trump drone bombings
went up now the point still stands that
as the drone bombings went up we didn't
win the war you know they still didn't
do anything so we have to get out
completely and it's at the point now
where when you've got
you know three trillion dollar spending
bills all these bailouts and stuff like
ron paul always said um empires end for
financial reasons
and you know we might not we might be
right on the moral issue we might be
right on the constitutional issue but
apparently nobody cares um we will be
right and we and they will understand
eventually on the financial aspect
just one one quick other thing too is
that this is not the disaster yet maybe
it will be but it's not what everyone's
pretending it is in afghanistan they're
acting like isis just seized western
iraq and that they're cutting people's
heads off that the taliban is
slaughtering people so far it's like
look there's some ugly things yes no
there have been some people dying but
i'm saying it's not like the taliban
have been rolling in and just
slaughtering everybody so far it's kind
of like eh it's an ugly withdrawal it's
not like some unbelievable nightmare
like many other of these situations have
been after we've gone chad memes like
they're like they're on they're on like
a people they're bad they're bad people
but by the way so were a lot of the
warlords that we propped up to fight the
taliban well let's talk about long-term
solutions all right now the republican
party doesn't do anything i mean they
sit around you got a handful of people
you know obviously rand paul i'm a big
fan and thomas massey's pretty good
but for the most part what is it a speed
bump for democrats then you got the
democratic party which are just like you
take and steal whatever you can and then
you've got the the lulbertarians of the
libertarian party you've got a lot of uh
we're familiar weird tweets and i've
never honestly taken the libertarian
party seriously uh even though neither
did i for most of my libertarian life
right right and so then i started
hearing more more more and more about
what you guys were doing i saw more
videos from you we had you on the show
several times and i'm like can you guys
you know build together something that
actually functions as a legitimate
alternative for for regular americans
who are just fed up well so right there
like what you just said is almost
exactly like the idea here right that
it's like well look we recognize what's
happening here so the the democratic
party is just
so laughably beyond hope at this point
it's now become a mix of the home for
neocons corporatists and their useful
woke idiots like that is basically the
the democrats from top to bottom at this
point there is like cronenberg yes yeah
it's it's just the it's it's beyond even
discussing the republican party has
really i mean i think
we see what it is i mean the the rank
and file there are certainly some people
there who are really like and i will say
in the democrats there are some
rank-and-file people who like tulsi and
bernie for the right reasons too so i
shouldn't be too hard on them the rank
and file like voters in the in the
republican base they really have
rejected the neoconservatives um but
they both see hey if you like tulsi well
how's she gonna be treated by this party
hey if you like bernie how's he gonna be
treated by this party if you like uh
donald trump how was he treated by his
own party he had to win in such a
landslide to even take that thing over
and by the way i am no fan of donald
trump but he was completely boxed in by
his own government his entire presidency
the man was framed for treason by his
own deep state so what are really like
and and the truth is even if donald
trump were to win and not be boxed in or
even if bernie sanders were to win and
not be boxed in they're both so
ideologically wrong on so many issues
that they wouldn't even know the best
way to take on the federal government
the reality is that what we need is a
mass awakening of american people to
understand to all be together on what
the problems are we don't have to agree
on everything but we can agree on the
most basic things which is that the
government needs to stop doing the evil
things that are destroying the country
and to me
the libertarian party you're right there
are there are some alberts there and
there are also there are also some
really good people running the
libertarians of course i would say most
i was specifically referring to the
libertarians as kind of a weight on the
libertarians yes but the thing is that
the vast majority like you you had
talked about before that you ran a poll
a couple years ago your audience and
that the vast majority of your audience
the biggest demographic the plurality uh
thought of themselves as libertarian and
there's all these people the libertarian
party is way smaller than the
libertarian movement yes than the
liberty movement and so we're like look
there is this party here that claims to
be about libertarian principles the
beautiful ron paul principles that we
stand for and there's way more of us so
if we want to all join this party we can
actually make this a force for the most
beautiful political philosophy in human
history which is that of individual
liberty and that really does solve so
many of the problems that the country
faces today and that's that that's
basically the thing is that we want to
save the nation
by destroying the government
and the government policies that are
destroying the nation it's um it's a
malice uh quote from i forget what
podcast but he's like i i hate the
government because i love the country
yeah
oh my god well i was going to speak to
what you said because it's interesting
like you kind of in a way
proved his point with you're saying like
oh i love thomas massey i love ron paul
or rand paul obviously we all love ron
paul none of these and these are the
biggest libertarian let's say stars in
the in the country
that's where all the support is that but
but that and that but the thing is
that's important to recognize in that is
that that is what the majority of
libertarians are like they're more
attuned to that so the problem is is
that the institution has been captured
by a small number of people because it
was essentially
given away apathy so we're just bringing
that movement back into the party to
actually represent it which is
wrong now i want to say one thing
there's probably a lot of people that
are just like i don't care about
politics i don't care about democrats
republicans or libertarians to them i
say
wouldn't you like to see press secretary
michael malus just because it would be
funny but that's another thing so this
is another thing
well absolutely and this is another
thing that we kind of as the mises
caucus bring to the table that is not
currently on the table within the
libertarian party which is that the
libertarian the libertarians need to
become a cultural movement and and and
have something to say there and have
have a narrative to right there yeah and
that's what's going to draw people in
right now the party is mired in this
idea that well we're just here to elect
candidates and then they don't even do
that so it's like what's your pitch and
and we are out here so like for example
we the mises caucus we have uh we're
supporting uh health freedom rallies you
know we're supporting like nurses that
are being threatened with the mandate we
just produced a documentary following uh
well our california crew produced a
documentary uh following three business
owners as the lockdowns came in and they
were
excellent documentary yeah and and um
you know we're we got an anti-war rally
going on on 9 11 in in dc
um stop the damn wars.org or end the
damn wars.org you know and uh
we're trying to actually get into the
culture and i would say you
are a big part of that because like
where i think libertarians are going to
gain the most ground is in the dissident
communities you know the the the the the
media is not up for grabs that or the
audience that is listening to the the
legacy media is not up for grabs but
it's got to be libertarians and i don't
mean big l libertarian like libertarian
party yeah i just mean on the spectrum
because
even the problem i have with left
libertarians as a compass faction you
you need only look at
political compass memes on reddit to
understand the problem we have right now
whenever they make a meme they show the
tankies the you know the authoritarian
communist types in the authoritarian
left they show nazis in the
authoritarian right and caps in the
libertarian right and the woke and the
libertarian left which makes literally
no sense because woke people are
dogmatic authoritarians they it's
cancelled culture it's
do it or else it's we want you to
believe our thing otherwise you you're
bad and wrong it's not libertarian at
all well yeah and and just the um the
fundamental underpinnings of say like
critical work
critical race theory critical theory
sorry but it kind of works yeah uh but
the like the philosophical underpinnings
of critical race theory are completely
incompatible with any type of of market
system at all i mean they will actually
tell you that meritocracy itself is
racist or that uh um liberal economies
meaning in the classical liberal sense
are racist so but check it out here's
the thing about left libertarianism it's
cooper left libertarian is cooperative
libertarian
libertarianism right is competitive so
the reason why i think right libertarian
is outsized is because it's really easy
to have a very large system where it's
like that's a fine beer you've got i
will trade you this rock and then we
come to an agreement cooperation outside
of an exchange of value is very very
difficult so left libertarianism is
crippled but this idea that left
libertarians are the woke you know
bernie sanders democrat that is not true
bernie sanders was maybe but the problem
is ultimately
uh we we were talking we i think we we
we talked about this with vosh who's a
he's a socialist we had him on on our
bonus segment we talked about this
a left libertarian system like the true
libertarian freedom is like
10 people on a farm who are have
agreements and they can solve their
problems very easily among each other
but once you try and scale up to two
different communities that don't agree
and you have no means by with to
exchange value and have a trade then you
get authoritarianism when one side says
do it or else right exactly so so what
it comes down to really is like like by
the way there are some really good left
libertarians out there who i have no
problem with and if you basically say if
you if you come to the conclusion of
volunteerism which many of them do where
it's kind of like okay well if you guys
don't want to be a part of this or you
guys want to go be you know competitive
or whatever the thing is which i don't
even think exactly describes our type of
libertarianism it's an aspect of it but
that as long as you're okay with that
and not forcing other people in then to
me we're all kind of the same thing and
you're just putting emphasis on
different areas if you can go have your
commune on a farm nobody's no no
libertarian like me or michael is going
to advocate for stopping you from doing
the presupposition is you own a farm
property right like how did you get that
and that's did you take that from you
did you see the meme
someone tweeted what what are you going
to do once communism is accomplished and
then someone responded with probably
study a bit more hang out with my
friends teach people how to you know
grow food on my farm maybe hang out on
sundays and then someone responded with
your farm
have these people ever looked at a
communist country right because you you
you don't own it right it is owned by
the greater and that means everyone is
subjugated yeah look i mean that type of
that type of system every time it's been
has tried has been not just like hasn't
worked out well it works out really
really disastrously bad but this is this
is my this is my here's the thing if
you're truly worth this this is why the
left libertarian on on internet on the
internet and how they portrayed is
completely wrong because if you were
left libertarian you would be cheering
for right libertarians because you all
agree leave each other alone unless you
come to an agreement so when when i saw
ron paul i was like
works for me he's going to leave me and
my friends alone and we'll go have our
little hippie commune and then we can do
our thing
couple things in my experience a lot of
times left libertarians like you use the
word cooperation i would argue that free
markets are cooperation and they
naturally produce hierarchies and a lot
of times uh left libertarians
want to flatten those hierarchies which
is just against nature
yeah no 100 so i i think that's exactly
right so if you think about say like
someone operating within a free market
or some type of business or something
like that you could describe it as
competition so you could say right now
you know you the that this show right is
in competition with other shows and
there is some degree of truth to that i
mean someone is choosing right now to
watch this show rather than watching
some other show so you're competing with
them but to just describe what you do as
competition it's like well i don't know
you are in a cooperative agreement with
everybody who's here to come and do the
show and you're going to come and you're
going to do this and they'll come in and
well you are in a cooperative agreement
with the travel accommodations made for
everybody to get here you're in a
cooperative agreement with your sponsors
you're in a cooperative agreement with
the people you buy the equipment from so
to me i see a lot more cooperation than
i do competition it's not that that's
not there but all of it is involved but
so i don't think it's like it's not one
or the other right exactly so so the
question becomes like how are we going
to relate to each other but what
ultimately my point was the true
rare left libertarians who tend to be
the politically homeless
should be paying attention to what you
guys are doing agreed and yeah because
if we can all agree like we're going to
be left alone we can all
look ron paul said he's like you can
have your own socialist commune within a
libertarian system why aren't you doing
it you know what made me an ancap
what's that uh i i interviewed ron paul
i organized a rally at every federal
reserve building simultaneously and that
earned me like a private interview with
ron paul
and i was struggling with the whole
thing at that time and i said ron
in a free society do you think
capitalism and socialism could like if
it's voluntary like run parallel to each
other
sure why not that was his answer i was
like
i think they have to you know it's
because if you're born into a system
like this where it's like you know
competition cooperation but then google
has monopolized an aspect of society how
do you use the you got to use the
government to break that up in my
opinion if you guys have other ideas
around that let me know well i
i think it's it's it's the taking away
of the free market that's produced that
because it's the collusion between
government so what is the incentive for
them to break it up you know i mean
they're the ones who are
getting that are colluding with those
corporate entities so what we need is
more freedom not necessarily more
government busting up of the the uh
corporations at least in my opinion yeah
i mean i certainly think that it's it's
hard to make the case you know there's
there's this tendency i think when a
problem is very hard to solve and that's
not to downplay what the problem is but
there's this tendency to say when
there's a problem well let's just have
government do it like but okay we have
all government has done is made google
stronger and stronger they like michael
was saying they have no interest in
breaking google up now if you think the
easier thing to do
is overtake the government get really
good people elected there and then break
them up in the best interest of the
people i i just i i'm highly skeptical
that we'll be able to do that
well that's that's it right so what you
actually but what you just like kind of
indicated there is you actually want
less government control that you want to
actually break their software code not
let them have protection under the law
and and you know what i mean so that
like that's my thing now a lot of
libertarians will make these really
stupid arguments that like tech
censorship and tech monopolies aren't a
big problem you know that's just the
market that is really stupid it is a
major major threat and it's a big
problem and let me say also to michael's
point a lot of these things and this is
this is something that i think is done
on the left a lot right i remember one
time just quick very quick anecdote that
bernie sanders was criticizing ron paul
and he said this was on msnbc and he
they played a clip of ron paul where he
said ron paul was like well what if
somebody doesn't buy insurance and then
they get in a motorcycle accident are
you telling me that they just have to
beg for charity or something and ron
paul goes look that's what freedom's all
about you take your own risks you make
your own choices you can ask for help
but you don't get to force people to
help you and bernie sanders it cuts back
to bernie sanders and bernie sanders
goes listen i like ron paul i think he's
a nice guy but that's what he believes
he believes
people
shouldn't get medical care that they
just shouldn't get it now meanwhile
bernie sanders is a career politician
ron paul is a medical doctor who worked
at a church and never turned anyone away
for a dollar an hour when he was young
okay so here's the thing it's nice to
just say oh government has to do this
thing and then feel like the
humanitarian in the room but the reality
is that we need to get on the ground and
change the culture in a lot of these
areas a lot of the stuff and this is
what michael was getting at before a lot
of this stuff with the the tech
censorship is that we have kind of given
up on this culture of free speech not
just and i don't mean the first
amendment i mean like free speech what
the first amendment was alluding to well
hold on hold on this is very important
the concept of free speech as we know it
is new
george george crowley got arrested for
saying naughty that's true that is true
it was it was what was it brandenburg v
ohio was that the case i'm not sure in
the 60s where we finally said oh
actually you can yell fire in a crowded
theater that's right right and people
have never learned the truth and bruce
got arrested too and that yeah something
happened in the 90s and 2000s where we
were like free speech family guys south
park simpsons they were just like we're
gonna make a whole bunch of off-color
jokes and people are gonna roll with it
and have a good time and now we so i i
genuinely to your point back then even
right in the 90s they would have those
shows like you you would see like on
those those kind of like trashy talk
shows during the day where they'd have
like
they'd have kkk guys come on yeah they
have like all these guys and there was
kind of a spirit of like
all right i think what you're saying is
awful but let's debate it and let's
hammer it out and like let's see what
you know what i mean
i wanna i wanna just wrap up that point
what we're seeing right now from the
democrats and the progressives is a
reactionary movement and i mean
reactionary in the sense that they are
opposed to
progress
they like to claim their progressives
they're not and i'll explain
critical race applied principles
hates the civil rights movement yeah
derek bell has criticized the the end of
segregation this is one of the prominent
preeminent critical race theorists
they do not like the changes that came
about and they want to switch it back to
the way things were 50 some odd years
ago they don't like the changes we've
we've gained with free speech they don't
like the fact that with the internet we
got even freer speech and it was crazy
so they are coming into power they are
pro-corporatist or you've got the
progressives who are just siding with
the establishment and they're trying to
rewind the clock on freedom of speech
and civil rights in california they had
a proposition in november that would
have stripped the civil rights provision
from their constitution and california
voted very very slim but they voted no
it was close
these progressives and democrats are
actively saying anti-discrimination laws
are bad eberm kendi is saying he wants
discrimination this is reactionary
reactionary literally means they want to
oppose the revolution identitarian law
was the law of the world for thousands
of years and it was only until the u.s
said civil rights were going to enforce
this and it was long and hard fought
freedom of speech only since like the
vietnam protests and everything have we
actually gained real freedom of speech
throughout the past several decades they
are taking all of that back they are
authoritarians
yeah i i think that's absolutely right
and they would uh oppose any reform
that still keeps the system going
because that by its very nature is white
supremacy this is like what the belief
is so this is the thing i want to say
about you guys
when you're when when you come out and
you're like war is bad we shouldn't we
shouldn't be having these wars what what
american for the most part is going to
be like i disagree there's some sure the
neocon types i suppose but regular
working americans overwhelmingly are
going to be like i have no idea why
we're doing it at stuff yeah and why am
i paying taxes for this most of them
don't even know about half the wars i
mean most of them don't even know we
have a war in somalia
or in yemen
yemen is like probably the worst thing
that's happening in the world right now
and nobody even knows about it the
greatest starvation of any human history
and then human history i think wasn't it
at least the past hundred years wasn't
it wikileaks that revealed a lot of the
stuff with yemen the cablegate stuff
they revealed a bunch of stuff uh going
on in yemen but that was i believe
before like the actual worst of it which
is really when the saudis went to war
with the houthis the point i wanted to
make with this is that
not everybody's going to agree with
everything you guys are for sure but it
seems like
what you guys are for is what most
people would say hey that's better than
the alternative and it's at least
something for the people so what does
the media say what is their response how
do they answer what it is you guys are
doing i mean they'll probably use every
media trick that they use you know i
mean that that's like i think to be
assumed at this point you know look when
if if you get close to being a threat to
the establishment you always are you
know whether it was tulsi gabbard was a
russian agent right as a russian asset
or something and bernie sanders was
leading a group of brown shirts and and
donald trump of course was the worst
nazi because he actually won right so
the but i think that americans are
becoming um
aware enough and cynical enough to to
kind of realize and and this is part of
the reason why the corporate press is
more and more desperate and erratic and
irrational is that they're losing their
grip on power that people you can only
do this so many times where you call
anyone who's a threat to you like a nazi
before people start to to wake up to
this and i did i saw a poll the other
day that said that you know two-thirds
of the american people say we never
should have uh
should have fought the war in
afghanistan and that's pretty powerful
stuff man the longest war in our history
over a trillion dollars something like a
couple hundred thousand uh people killed
let me let me ask you guys a question
real quick though how would you rate the
current state of the national economy
oh bad
yeah i mean uh like on the precipice of
disaster
uh what do you so uh i love this metric
i've been using it for the past week
independent voters the plurality say the
economy is fairly bad
republican voters the plurality says the
economy is very bad
uh in both groups it's overwhelming
majority saying the economy is very bad
republicans 73 percent say it's in the
bad category for uh independent voters
it's 67 percent what do you think
democrats think
oh i i already know the answer
it's uh the poor already says it's yeah
okay the majority says the economy is
fairly good yeah
how is that possible and i i bring that
up because what i think it represents is
there are a group of people living in
the matrix
they the media tells them everything's
fine you are happy everything's good
they believe it the council of foreign
relations
the media comes out and says the war is
a disaster and biden looks bad and these
people are the ones sitting there
gobbling it all up it's a coordinated
media campaign that's for sure well to
answer the question that you said
earlier what would happen like what
would the media's response be if we blew
up i don't think we have to speculate uh
like
we have some experience with this with
ron paul and believe it or not gary
johnson now gary johnson my opinion they
use them as a tool
um and johnson because he didn't have
the strength of principle that ron and
the courage and the consistency that ron
did he allowed himself to be used as a
tool so what i mean by that is um
you know everyone kind of goes back to
gary johnson in the whole uh aleppo
moment
but before that relatively speaking he
was being given
fair and consistent coverage
uh by libertarian party standards and uh
then what happened is now i i'm thinking
that what they thought is so
conventional wisdom is that the
libertarians pull more from the
republican than the democrat that's
actually not true um it's it's pretty
even actually
but
um
then the polling started to show that
he's hurting hillary a little bit more
and and and that's when the aleppo thing
happened that's when the fangs came out
because you know
he was he was peaking at 12 in the
polling yeah at one point and and
so for for people who don't know how the
debate commission works basically the
debate commission gets to pick five
polls you have and you as the
libertarian have to score 15 across
three of them and that's what gets you
in the debates which is a freaking crazy
bar
and he was actually on the precipice of
doing that it looked like he was hurting
hillary more then well that's valence
came out and everything changed but
let's be honest the aleppo moment was
his fault oh oh oh yeah oh you want to
know you wanna know how i always explain
this ask me about aleppo
what's aleppo well look look i'm not
here to talk about aleppo i want to keep
it focused on america and jobs and i
think the american people aren't
concerned about things like aleppo i
think they're mostly i mean
and gary gary but that's that's just
kind of sad
the better one of that or i mean like
that was that was a way better way to
handle it but do you remember this shows
you how much confidence and just not
giving in to the narrative that you've
been defeated is there was this one
moment in the debates it was my favorite
moment in the debates with donald trump
this back when there were all the
republicans and they asked donald trump
about their tpp the trans-pacific
partnership and he goes the major
problem in the trans-pacific partnership
is that it doesn't address china's
currency manipulation okay if you don't
address china's currency manipulation
you can't get anywhere it goes on this
whole thing about china's currency and
then round paul just raises his hand and
he goes
shouldn't someone point out that china's
not involved in the tpp
and donald trump goes rand paul why are
you way over there what are you like one
percent like you [ __ ] or something and
then it was just like this you just move
away from it you're like i i guess trump
won that exchange i don't know like what
even though he was like you could be
wrong and all listen gary johnson could
have been like i'm sorry what is aleppo
and they go aleppo syria and he goes oh
okay well the crisis in aleppo syria is
that but if he had just demonstrated
after that that he knew three things
about about syria he'd have been fine
but he just kind of started apologizing
and collapsing he was just bad politics
he's a good guy by the way gary johnson
but yeah have you guys ever seen the
future album episode where they they
they unfold the 80s businessman
so fry's he's like i'm from the area
same as you so he likes him and he
invites him into planet express and he
tells fry he's like what do you do when
someone asks about something you don't
know don't tell me about x i'll tell you
about x x is not the problem or
something like that just like politician
answers something beautiful i actually
think the gary johnson thing is a really
good cautionary tale on how to deal with
this stuff because compare it to ron
paul in 2012
the main thing that they tried to do
with ron paul in 2012 is block him out
and act like he didn't exist he was
getting first second place in in uh uh
straw or while all the straw polls he
was dominating especially the online
ones but he was actually like looking
like he was going to win iowa new
hampshire and they just they just said
well first place is such and such and
third places you know and just
completely wrote him out but what that
served to do
is
inflame the grassroots that much more
and then and and
they and the media can never admit that
it's wrong so it starts this cycle and
it's the same thing that happened with
jordan peterson you go out there and you
say the truth you say some bold [ __ ]
that's true
and and then uh the media wants to
destroy you for doing that for going
against their narrative and then if you
just play it right
they will you will get free press trump
did it in a too but in a different way
they will just continually
in their inability to admit that they're
wrong go after you again and again and
again and again
and and you can
you know snowball off that whereas
johnson
i think was happy just to be on the
media and and that allowed him to be
their tool which they were happy to do
and then they turned on him when it
looked like it wasn't going the way that
they anticipated we've got a really
simple solution for this it's just send
in michael malus
oh yeah
that will always be uh our solution
tactically whenever in doubt we hit the
malice but that's the button but people
need to understand michael is a genius
it's not just about his comedic wit
smart guy michael we're big fans it's
that he just knows so much he's got a
good memory he's got a good wit he's got
a good understanding of history and
philosophy
he would run circles around these oh
yeah oh yeah no that is our uh that is
our ace in the hole it's michael no
listen but that is also there's there's
something to the fact that and and i've
done a fair amount of like cable news
shows and um there are exceptions to
this there are some some really smart
and like impressive people in cable news
but they're few and far between and the
vast majority of people on there it is
astounding how little they know
how how weak their arguments are i mean
these are people like i'd say the
majority of people that you see on cable
news
straight up could not do a show like
this like they couldn't do a show where
you were just asking them about like oh
well what happened in 1914 or what
happened like they don't know
stuff and i'm not claiming to be the
expert who knows everything but like
michael malus knows way more than like
99 percent of them do and they may look
at him and be like oh this guy's a troll
and he's being a clown but that clown is
smarter than any of you guys and so but
this is an interesting thing too that's
different than the ron paul days it's
different than 2008 2012. there weren't
shows like this and rogan and and and a
whole bunch of other big patriots
yeah like these are these are huge
platforms that have very in-depth
interesting serious conversations that
reach audiences that are actually quite
a bit bigger than a lot of the corporate
press audiences and that is a whole new
like tool that if we really want to
change something in this country we'd be
crazy to not
recognize that there's a whole different
playing field by the way that's i think
a big part of the reason why the whole
corporate press is freaking out about
fake news and why we have to crack down
on all these voices because for the
first time i think really ever they've
lost their monopoly they now have real
competition there's some university who
did like a study or whatever and they
claimed that i'm a super i i was a super
spreader of election disinformation on
twitter and i just find that so
ridiculous because i my twitter is just
it's not a serious display of news it's
like i once i once tweeted you know
what's the greatest band and why is it
radiohead and then a bunch of people got
mad and then i said i said the foo
fighters are the greatest band of all
time and then people start like i don't
i don't use twitter in a way that but i
guess that's their argument ah that
proves it he just is posting garbage on
twitter that makes no sense but they put
me in the same category as like sydney
powell and lynn wood and i'm like i was
telling i was saying those people were
wrong the entire time
it's it's this what i think is with the
smear pieces that come out against me
they're scared of one very very big
thing
a lot of these big even right wing shows
they have funding somebody stepped up
and said we've got a ton of money we can
give you money to help you grow we don't
have that we just have the people who
are members at timcast.com so it's
literally just the people and we don't
have donors that are just like
mysteriously giving us large sums of
money doesn't exist it's all from the
most part i'll do the bernie sanders our
average contribution is ten dollars and
that's making this whole thing possible
that i think is a problem that they're
not going the establishment will not be
able to solve for because like you
mentioned with all these other shows
how do you just stop them while they're
censorship for sure so they can
certainly excise certain political
opinions
but the stuff we're talking about it's
not controversial people don't like war
and conflict and and theft and
administration and lockdowns and banker
bailouts and corporate bailouts and
militarized police and the idea of the
war on terrorism being turned inward
against the american people even if you
even if you really don't like
republicans i mean democrats like
democratic voters wake up man the
republicans were the ones who supported
the war on terrorism and now they are
the targets of the war on terrorism do
you really want to be the next people
who support the war on terrorism you
think you won't be the next targets of
it too like there are so many issues
here and and i think to your point tim
even if they were able to like even if
they were able to like get you booted
off of all media platforms or god forbid
something more authoritarian like they
you know some real crazy they snatch you
up and get and you know you throw you in
some prison and torture you know
whatever they could do they could shut
what do they do to your giant audience
who wants this type of stuff but you
think you think anyone who listens to
this show is then going to go turn on
don lemon
and watch him and and i'm not even
saying like you know what i mean like
it's not that like oh my god you're the
greatest journalist in the world it's
like that you're a journalist and he's
not
he's a propagandist like that's just not
anyone who's watching this show is
thinking they might be disagreeing with
everything i'm saying they might be
disagreeing with everything you're
saying but they're thinking when you
watch don lemon it's there to go fill me
with fluff so i can feel like i did my
part by knowing what's going on in the
world it's not they're not going back
into the matrix the people who watch
this show or any of the like real
alternatives like mediocre fox news
called me an investigative journalist
because i made some phone calls don't
buy the propaganda no no
positive or negative this is how crazy
things are uh you know a lot of these
smears against me will say like tim
pool's not a journalist and i usually
just say i'm like a commentator but i do
journalism i literally fact check all
day every day and i make phone calls i
call i [ __ ] i call for comments and so
when the vaccine mandate thing happened
i called the city to get i tried going
to the mayor's office they don't have
they have like an email web portal it
doesn't barely works and so i i called
the city they said no medical exemptions
i started calling various restaurants
they said no medical exemptions and fox
was like investigative journalist tim
poole and you know what i appreciate the
compliment or the statement of the work
i'm doing
but because these people in media don't
do that anymore to a great degree don't
get me wrong there's a lot of great
journalists on the ground in conflict
doing investigative work there's a lot
of non-profits that do it but much of
the new york media environment won't
even make a phone call and i'll give you
a really good example did you guys hear
about mayo gate
no what was this so this was probably a
bit esoteric for this show but there was
a story i saw go viral because the north
carolina gop tweeted out a quote from a
restaurant where they said i'm paying
200 more per week in mayonnaise
and they said bite inflation hits you
know north carolina
because the republicans tweeted it out
the left said there's no possible way
someone's spending 200
a week in mayonnaise they said if the
consumer price index
is a five point four percent increase
that means they'd have to be spending
three thousand seven hundred dollars on
mayonnaise per week for their for there
to be a two hundred dollar increase this
is ridiculous huffington post
independent n100 they all write it up
saying something's wrong in mayotown
this restaurant accused of lying you
know what i did i called the restaurant
and uh a guy answered the phone and i
said i see a quote from you in the in
the press that you uh are spending 200 a
week in mayonnaise because of inflation
and he went oh yeah so we go through
about um
you know uh 10 5 gallon buckets per week
they used to be 18 now they're about 36
so you know you do the math and i was
like oh
okay he goes yeah we use it for our
dressings and our sauces and it's in
recipes so we we kind of go through a
lot and i said what's the capacity of
your restaurant is it 250. i was like
that's a lot of people for any one time
so you imagine you go to a sunday
afternoon restaurant there's a 20-minute
wait because they're full you got 250
people they'll get mayo on their burger
they'll get ranch dressing on their
salads so that's how much mayo they used
these media outlets if you can even call
them that yeah didn't even make the
phone call to ask they saw a tweet and
said let's attack these people what
happened they sent a harassment campaign
at the restaurants of people saying
you're republican shills you're lying
about biden one story actually accused
the restaurant of blaming biden when the
restaurant was literally just giving one
simple quote saying yes our prices have
gone up thank you
it's really unbelievable that story is a
microcosm of what needs to be done
frankly like journalism well not just
journalism but you took initiative and
you did this one little thing and
through that got the bottom got to the
bottom of that story
and and right now our society is having
a serious dearth of courage and and
and action so like i if i may i kind of
want to take it because what started
this whole sprawling conversation was
you saying
long-term solutions like like long term
what do we do
um i think you're starting to see the
beginning of what has to be done with
all of these parents going to the school
board meetings yeah that's not that's
beautiful man to stop these mask
mandates but that's the thing you know
and crt well ncrt and and and um but you
see so like the conversation is around
the national news
so much you know and and who's producing
the national news story the mainstream
media
who do they serve
the government so like we're kind of
chasing a tale by doing that when really
the action is in the states and the
localities and there is a lot of action
going on there and one person can have
an impact by going locally i mean a
little story just in my personal
experience i know you know given the the
vaccine mandates and everything weed
isn't the biggest issue here but like
i'm just saying i as one person went to
two city council meetings where i live
in norristown pennsylvania had a
conversation with my chief of police
said what's going on with
decriminalization of weed and he said
you know what i don't know but it's time
it needs to be done i went and got some
draft legislation switched out the city
of lancaster with the municipality of
norristown gave it to the city council
told them hey you guys are all democrats
the democrat party of pennsylvania has
weed legalization in their platform
shouldn't take me some random
libertarian dude coming in here and
being like let's get this done this is a
slam dunk
a couple months later it was
decriminalized there you go
yeah i know you're you're absolutely
right that the only place that you're
going to make a real difference
politically is locally at this point the
the whole um particularly the federal
government apparatus is designed
like as you're saying jekyll island
right by design is there to protect the
powerful it's not there in the interest
of the people or of liberty but i i just
think that like like you said it's like
that stuff that's going on at local
levels especially there's something to
me really powerful about the parents
showing up to these uh meetings and just
saying we're not taking this anymore i
mean like how what type of level like
you know do you get to like there's got
to be a line somewhere right you're like
i'll tell you for me personally i mean
my kids like my wife's pregnant now and
i got a two and a half year old so
they're a little bit younger than
this you know being in this world yet
like they're still i i still protected
them protecting them completely but the
idea that you're gonna mask up my child
and then teach them race essentialism
um
no and like like uh over my dead body
like i mean like literally if there's if
anything is worth dying over that is
worth dying over like you you know
forget to like you know you'll pry my
gun from my cold dead hands like you're
probably my kid from my cold dead hands
there is no chance i'm going to let
allow my kid to be propagandized in the
most
abusive manner i i just don't know how
you know and it's it's really heartening
to see parents standing up against well
let's uh let's go to super chats yes we
got we got a lot of people without a
good comment so smash that like button
and i just got to start from where it
real quick because gary talent says when
are you going when are you going to
rename the show the michael malus fan
hour
um i mean it's not a bad idea yeah
definitely we'll read it um
michael malus fan irl fan cast irl it's
just we just said here yeah just stand
for for michael it's got a ring to it we
we quote him more often than anybody
else
you know like he's a writer from like
the 1950s you know well you're starting
a network right like you could make that
one of the shows heck yeah the michael
mouse fan hour
uh and then we got one this is really
interesting i haven't seen this mitchell
davis says biden just banned import of
russian ammo this will cause ammo to
skyrocket where no one can afford it
there will be a shortage and companies
won't have won't have to compete only
rich will have it gun control wow
i didn't hear that
you know there's a there's another story
that i just saw related to the gun
control issue where um again it goes
back to my the states and the localities
and everything are where the action's at
missouri
the state of missouri passed a law
saying that neither the state government
nor the localities are going to be
enforcing federal gun control law and
now that's a supreme court issue
yeah you told me about that earlier
today that is very interesting
all right trip sucks says last night in
sf i went to see a play vax cards were
checked and matched to people's ids at
the door dozens were turned away no
refunds my family had to literally sneak
past the guards to get in also hamilton
is cringe
you know we were just thinking about
this uh in new york city a human rights
a willful human rights violation is
fined at 250 000
a vaccination card fine is one thousand
dollars then i think it's 2 500 and then
5 000 and i think the 5000 is the cap
for violation
so i thought about what would happen if
you know i just brought of some friends
who had who had disabilities barring
them from getting vaccinated went to a
random restaurant in new york walked in
and as soon as the person said okay you
got to show your proof of id or vaccine
i'd say well i'm not actually here to
come in i'm just a legal observer
because i've got some disabled people
who are going to try and enter and if
you deny them it's a human rights
violation under new york city state and
federal law i'm just curious to see what
what which fine you're more scared of
the 250 000 human rights violation or a
thousand dollar covet violation coming
in guys let's see what he does i'll be
filming by the way
just like how will the shops react to
that because the government has put them
in a position where they literally
cannot escape this
and the important point i brought up
several times now is these companies
have to fire their employees so now
we're now we're talking about him like
labor rights so so listen
if you live in new york or san fran new
orleans or los angeles and your company
mandates you to get a vaccine but you
legally like you medically can't because
your doctor is barring you
then you can take it up with i think
this would be the eeoc
equal employment opportunity commission
i think what's called and they handle
discrimination now the problem is the
local government you may get cult
establishment people being like we don't
care get out
but if your doctor legitimately says and
and this happens all the time there's
people who can't get it
you can't then it is in i don't think
it's an opinion i think is a fact that
you are being discriminated against
based on a disability that is not fair
and it violates the law let's see how
these new york businesses handle this
not to mention what would happen if like
100 people tried walking into one
restaurant and none of them had id on
them
the whole restaurant would be jammed up
and unable to operate because they've
got an id everybody at the door it just
wouldn't work yeah and so then they
an hour of checking ids and
business can't operate
you know what people
you can't tolerate fascism
all right let's see we got
torin danowski says dave i just joined
the mises caucus in philly this week
because of you thanks for pointing me to
freedom minded people in progressive
city oh yeah yeah well thank you and
that's uh that's michael's uh hometown
that's uh close to me and uh we're
looking into uh you guys had maj toure
on the show yeah yeah oh my god that's
my guy dude is awesome he's a rat dude
yeah and he uh
at some point soon he's he's opening up
the solutionary center it's like a
community center gun range and the
philly libertarian party is looking to
start hosting their meetings there so
that should be really cool right
all right let's see we got
joseph groschek says my company is
trying to force me to get the shot now
now here's my issue
doctors are the ones who'd be trying to
convince you not force you and so the
the challenge i the problem had with all
of this is like
bro your manager at your supermarket
doesn't know your medical history
shouldn't be telling you to do anything
so you go to your doctor
and you and you figured out we had kurt
schlichter on the show he's a good dude
and his doctor is conservative and he
said he's talked to his doctor about you
know his his condition like his age and
like his risk factors and all that and
doctor said i recommend it he said all
right and he's here and he's fine
but to force people without knowing
anything about
there's there's two big things that i
don't like here
forcing people to out their disabilities
and demanding id
not not not to mention demanding a
medical procedure is none of your
business like yeah
i mean just like the idea of like
creating this two-tier cast system where
not everyone has these basic you know
fundamental rights to participate in
society as is outrageously creepy the
slippery slope is just
unfathomable i mean like it's it's you
know you've now got especially now that
biden's already pushing boosters so what
are you saying this is just forever now
by the way kovit's never going away
there will be variants here with us for
it's a coronavirus it's going to be here
without that's only because you're
unboxed dave yeah
real quick though there's there's
something interesting there isn't the
libertarian party opposed to the civil
rights law
well i mean the libertarian i don't know
what the official libertarian party
position is but i'll tell you that the
idea of banning discrimination
from by private businesses would be in
conflict with pure libertarian
principles uh so the idea that if you
own a business like in the same way that
you can discriminate
who you want to have as a guest on your
show and who you don't want to have as a
guest on your show you could
discriminate based on race or gender or
something like that i don't have to
agree with it but i could accept that
that's your right however this we're
talking about the government forcing you
to discriminate against a
certain group and now you're getting
into jim crow
categories i mean again i'm just saying
like i don't know what other legal
president to cite that would be forced
discrimination by private businesses
under the law jim crow comes to mind
this is this is interesting the inverse
would actually be actually be if private
businesses started saying they were
choosing to discriminate against people
who weren't in the vaccination and the
government said you can't do that
anymore that's we're not even at that
level we're at the level where the
government is forcing the businesses and
the businesses i talked to when i called
said we're sorry we don't want to do
this we're just following the mayor's
orders so yes and and by the way as much
as i would
be appalled and hate it if businesses
were voluntarily discriminating against
um non-vaccinated people although i will
say perhaps there could be some
businesses where it made sense okay like
i saw like some cruise lines doing it
and i i kind of understand we're on
cruise ships they'd be concerned
although this was before the delta
variant we found out you could still get
it and pass it along and all that but
but i'll just say as much as i would be
appalled by that i wouldn't support
legislating that they're not allowed to
do that having the government forced
them to not do that i would however say
you know what you're going to lose a ton
of business and just get completely
destroyed in the market for this dumb
decision and blast them okay i'm going
to read the super chat but first i want
to ask a quick question for some people
who uh who may need clarification
you guys are not for open borders
no no no it's it's the
so here it gets it gets sticky because
there's there is a spectrum within
libertarianism so you've got
anarchists you've got small government
types and because of that it it creates
a spectrum of what is canon within
libertarianism right so like but the
mises caucus is not for open borders
there is there are probably some people
in the mises caucus who are and some
people who aren't no there's a lot of
people in the mises caucus who are who
are open borders but our official
position on borders is that because
there is so the idea of the mises caucus
is that we focus on the 80 percent that
libertarians agree on
the wars the the growth of government
taxes all this stuff and and not on the
stuff that divides us like borders um
and and uh you know people can get
really zealous about the open border
thing and because there legitimately is
a spectrum of thought that's what i
would call canon within libertarianism i
mean just the idea that well the
borderlands should be owned by the
government versus borderlands should be
uh privately owned that that really
creates a spectrum of two different
strains of thought so we just basically
we don't have an official position on
that if you want to like if you were
within that spectrum you're cool with us
yeah all right well i'll just say like
my position on the issue because i know
there are people in the mises caucus who
are open borders and there are who are
not i am not for open borders and i
don't think that that's the proper
libertarian position the idea that
that libertarianism is basically to me
the the belief that you own yourself
um that you you believe in the
non-aggression principle and private
property rights that's more or less
where you where you get libertarianism
free markets the whole you know
philosophy and borders are private
borders the idea the idea that if the
government has commons that those
commons should be open to everybody is
not at all deduced from libertarian
principles and the truth is that if the
government taxes or as libertarians
believe robs from the domestic
population right that's that's our
belief that it's theft from the domestic
population to create commons then those
commons have more of a rightful claim by
the domestic population than any foreign
population so i am not i'm not an open
borders libertarian i personally
fall on on dave's side of that argument
but as a matter of our platform yeah
yeah right on arianemicus says
thank you for covering the food
shortages over the past few weeks i've
been trying to convince my roommate to
pitch in for emergency supplies
including food and it has helped us
prepare you can always go to safe and
ready meals we uh save readymeals.com we
haven't done a promo for them in quite
some time but uh that's the stuff that
we have yeah that's great to have i mean
look man after 2020 if you didn't think
maybe it's a good idea to have like some
some type of supply of food for i i
think you know i would just say i think
it's very wise to do as much of that as
you can a big part of the famine in
yemen is caused by saudi arabian uh
airstrikes
on their water supply yes they destroyed
their environment to be clear what saudi
arabia is conducting is with no
exaggeration a war of genocide with the
intention of genocide they are starving
the population intentionally and the u.s
this was launched under obama you can go
look this up google play obama placate
the saudis he literally said we had to
support them in this war to placate them
because you know we had kind of pissed
him off with the iraq war and the iran
deal so here let's throw the saudis a
bone and and give them a war of genocide
the reason
we're going to say i'm sorry i i to make
it even more ass backwards
our original involvement in in yemen was
under bush
as part of the war on terror because
they have the uh al-qaeda in the arabian
peninsula it's a huge al-qaeda cell that
is in yemen so you know who the best
fighting force against al-qaeda in the
raven peninsula is the houthis oh yeah
so this is the the other the other like
little twist to throw into obama
supporting the which by the way trump
continued all four years of his
presidency so don't let him off the hook
for this either and and made huge deals
with with the saudis but yeah so you
have the houthis fighting against the
saudis al qaeda on the side of the
saudis america coming in on the side of
al qaeda and the saudis fighting against
the houthis who were the enemies of al
qaeda originally to some extent
supporting the houthis as part of war on
terror and then just like the mujahideen
it all flipped and well listen they that
that's the other thing that's so
criminal and this really falls on obama
and trump was a little bit better but
not much but but better than obama on
this is that in libya syria and in yemen
he fought on the side of al qaeda and in
both libya and yemen actually funded and
armed al qaeda and you know a lot of
people throw the term treason out
but the literal definition of treason
is giving aid and armed and arms to the
enemy right during war and that is what
obama and john brennan uh and and as
well as you know some other powerful
people are guilty of keegan hotter says
dave i know you don't believe in
intellectual property and piracy tim i
know you strongly believe in these
things please discuss
so you don't believe in intellectual
property and uh and and piracy well i
don't believe in intellectual property
in the sense that it's property you know
so it's it's not that there there should
be like this is like kind of abstract
philosophical stuff but the idea that
like if someone takes your property you
have a right to use force to stop them
from taking your property if someone
downloads your podcast or something like
that without permission no listen you
can make agreements with different
companies that host it that penalize
them in some way but what i mean is that
it's not a property right in the same
way i agree that a physical property
right is a property right so you make
contractual agreements with someone and
you protect against that but no do i
think someone could be thrown in jail
for like downloading music
illegally no
we we agree i i think if someone steals
your property you have a right to take
it back right in some way if someone so
it's criminal versus civil i think kind
of right more or less i think piracy and
stealing someone's intellectual property
is a civil thing it's like you take him
to court you assume you say hey look
this was something i developed and then
they ripped it off somehow and the
criminal criminal criminal action could
be if they hacked it or something yeah
well that's a that's a whole different
story because hacking is kind of
breaking into something yeah yeah so
that's kind of a different thing um but
i also think that most of the time that
type of stuff should be dealt within the
realm of contractual agreements exactly
so we're trying to figure out
technological solutions so like if you
sold my song on the web uh you'd get
paid with a cryptocurrency that would
automatically detect that i was the
creator and siphon a percentage of the
payment to the creator right so that you
could have like entice a thousand people
to sell my mp3s and i would give them
each one percent of every sale so you
have people like organizing huge
websites of like aggregated music to
sell where they'd be making them what
happened and also just that the the
truth is that intellectual private like
we're all using like almost like the
most generous examples where we would
all be kind of sympathetic like yeah you
shouldn't really take that person's work
with that but the way intellectual
property is actually enforced through
the law there are far more egregious
violations of that where like the the
like look the idea almost in like the
most abstract sense right it's like if
you were on a desert island and you and
you and you found like some shells and
and you made like a necklace like a
shell necklace out of that and you're
like well i worked that took me like an
hour to do so that's my property i mixed
my labor with the earth you know the
most lock-in just acquisition of
property that's my property and someone
ran up and snatched it off your neck
you'd be like that person's a thief i
think you have the right to go tackle
them and take it back that's yours you
worked for that not them but if you went
and made a little shell necklace and
then said i am now the creator of shell
necklaces and anyone else who makes a
shell necklace i own the intellectual
property of shell necklace and now if
someone else made it i'm going to go rip
that off your neck because i am the well
now you're the aggressor not the one so
that's where like intellectual property
gets into this weird area where you
can't just it's a little bit different
if you claim something like your podcast
or your art or your creation but you
can't just like the idea of just
creating a product and then claiming
that you own all
future ones is a little bit
all right to me zanzibar says i was
raised democrat swung right during trump
but embraced libertarianism when i found
the lpmc i've never wanted to join a
party more dave smith for president
there you go that's a rumor that's a
rumor yeah
i haven't heard it
all right sir youtube says you need to
have george gammon on the show his
recent video on bitcoin was excellent
he's held events with ron paul and g
edward griffin as the headliners and
he's also open to traveling you could
also ask him about the suit against the
federal reserve he's embarked on ooh i'd
like to hear that that all sounded like
an excellent recommendation to me you
know the greatest thing about wokeness
is what's that well there's there's two
things that you need to understand first
is get go broke right and then the fact
that the federal reserve has been
embracing woke policies so i'm kind of
like oh man i don't know maybe
the federal reserve getting woke what
does that mean the fed the c.i.a
they got a lot the fed going broke
without loosening up legal tender laws
would be ugly
i want to have george griffin on the
show have you worked with them before no
i mean like i've i've watched you know a
bunch of his videos and read a bunch of
his stuff but i've never would you want
to come on the show with him yeah dude
if you get g edward grifford on i'll
yeah absolutely dude i'll come on
anytime with him yes i might be able to
help you with that okay let's do it that
sounds great
he wrote the book on jekyll island right
creature from jekyll island from jack
violin and he also i mean he's been like
uh he's been at it forever man like he's
been he's been on top of this stuff
ruben pedroza says the real way to make
change in government is to enforce term
limits or elections for all bureaucratic
positions of power fire the deep state
yeah what do you guys think about term
limits i mean i personally don't think
it would make too much of a difference
because it doesn't change the inherent
incentives it just shortens the time
frame on them i think i think that's
true i think it actually might uh even
have more perverse incentives you know
like where you could have someone likes
like well you got a short little time
span you better cash in right now for
all the revolving door value you could
get you know um but i also think that
it's like all of these solutions almost
presume
the victory
so okay we're going to enforce term
limits on all bureaucrats and all
politicians well how the heck do we do
that unless we already have control of
the entire government right you know
what i mean like so so what's the step
to get to there a lot of people always
want to have these silver bullet
solutions but the truth is that what we
really need is to wake up a lot more
people otherwise none of these solutions
really work it's cultural yeah yeah
culture 100
all right wifey says you are missing the
depths of hassan's hypocrisy he told
sargon in a debate two years ago quote
profit is theft sargon to say that then
buy a three million dollar house i'ma
stop right there because i ain't gonna
straw man hassan when the left says
profit they don't mean the simple money
you make off your labor what they're
referring to is when a ceo gets paid 13
million dollars a year and then somebody
who actually makes say the bottle of
water
they sell the bottle of water for five
dollars extract a dollar from you know
to go upwards towards a position
somewhere else the the general issue is
scale
so where as we talk about free
enterprise and capitalism is in a way
they don't understand and they need to
if i build a birdhouse and the materials
are 20 bucks and i sell for 25 i have a
five dollar profit
hassan is not referring to that five
dollars he's saying oh but you made it
you're entitled to sell it it's yours
they're talking about hospitals that
have board board members who don't do
anything just
absorb money and so their view of it is
if you are in a position as like a
shareholder or something and you're
getting dividends and profits but you're
not doing any work that's the profit
they're talking about so you can agree
with them or disagree with them but i
like to steal man their arguments and
then have the argument fair enough yeah
but i think you guys are very much in
favor of if you own the business and
hand it off to somebody else so you can
take the money right yeah absolutely and
i i also wouldn't suggest i mean look
again like what what has to be made
clear is that we live in a system and an
economy that is completely um you know
it's it's nothing but a big cartel
scheme and the rules are completely
rigged for the powerful but if we're
just talking in theory in a voluntary
free market or something close to that
the idea that someone who's an investor
did nothing i mean no i don't think they
did nothing they invested in that
company i mean go ask someone who's
starting a company how important
investors are they're really really
important and you know what if you don't
have them the whole thing doesn't get
made so i don't believe in that i don't
i don't think profit is is evil in any
way in fact i think it's a sign that a
company is doing really well
john says hassan also said he uh also
has even said he couldn't do more
in-depth analysis of videos without
hiring more people so his hours of
streaming is not an actual hustle
i disagree
i mean being on camera for 10 hours a
day is work man he does it almost every
day i respect him for 10 hours a day
yeah that's correct yeah that's that's
impressive that's a hustle dude i'll say
that is impressive
and i i don't think we need to straw man
our our political opponents or rivals or
people we disagree with we need to
always be like here's the best they have
to offer and let's
prove it wrong
so look
i would i i say if you're truly for the
cause you would invest in it hassan is
an activist he's a commentator he's a
progressive socialist
he chose to use his money for a three
million dollar house as opposed to a
three million dollar advocacy
organization
now that's fine he doesn't have to do
anything and he says he says that you
just don't see the efficacy he work he
does because he's not pushing it out
there for a pr campaign
and that's that may be true but i'm just
like three million dollar house in west
hollywood you could move to pasadena for
a fraction of that cost for a seventh
for the cost so if you want to have that
big fancy house in west hollywood you
are choosing to live in the upper
echelon of the wealthy ultra elites that
i think is a fair criticism but i don't
think we need to criticize the fact that
he's working really hard can i tell you
uh he made a video trashing me once and
uh he straw manned me pretty bad and
then i made a video back
smashing him and uh
i kind of now that i know he does 10
hours a day i take a lot less offense to
it i'm like well he's got to come up
with something man i mean he's doing 10
hours a day yeah you got to bang out
whatever you can hey look look the left
straw man's and they no you're right
that doesn't mean lines that doesn't
mean we need to so that's like that
that's a good point and especially if
you're right if you're right like if
you're right you don't you shouldn't
want to censor other people i don't mean
right-wing i mean if you're correct
right you shouldn't want to censor other
people and you shouldn't need a
strongman other people because you got
the truth on your side he said some
really awful things in the past yeah you
know about like dan crenshaw about 9 11.
but you but people always try to bring
that stuff up and i'm like the reason i
don't bring up people saying dumb things
in the past is because it's not a
political argument it's just you you're
it's an ad hominem it's like look at
this guy he says dumb things i'm like
probably i say dumb things too yeah no
one should have judged no one should be
judged over the worst thing you said
there should be some amount of like a
charitable grace that it's like well
let's judge you on like kind of what you
stand for over your you know like the
the body of your work not just like this
one sentence or this one thing you said
that's like kind of gotcha nonsense yeah
well you know
we're not perfect here i rag on people i
try to avoid being super mean as well i
used to like really be can't stand them
offensive with my jokes back when i was
like 15 18 i was all about like
impressing my friends and using the most
racist just joke just terrible and then
i realized that was back on monday for
me
i realized in college i was like kind of
broadened to a larger you know sect of
of humanity and i realized that it was
offensive to other people that making
humans the butt of jokes isn't
necessarily the best way to do comedy so
i kind of changed the way i had it just
don't do the comedy where you make fun
of yourself yeah don't do that either
let's read this one we got a good one
brett stubbs says dave left off a huge
motivation in the history of the irs it
was also to do away with old banknotes
from local banks you could only pay
taxes in the federal reserve note so it
was also for consolidation of a single
note
yeah well there's
there's definitely something to be said
for that that's that's a very
interesting point but of course yeah
that is true that it really strengthens
kind of legal tender right because the
only thing you can pay your your taxes
in is right what federal reserve notes
right there you go
cody says tim i'm coming up on the
one-year anniversary of my father's
passing it's been a harder time than
i've ever faced before you and crowder
have been my favorite therapy i love all
of you keep it up hey man
sad to hear about your father's passing
but uh thanks for being a fan and
watching the show and i'm glad that it's
uh it's been helpful we're just some
dudes who hang out and talk stuff on the
internet and we have friends over so you
know we do our best
if the magician says you are the means
of production tim
individuals are
there's another thing i brought up in
the hassan thing in my earlier segment
because it was actually pretty long i
have way more to say about today yeah i
did i ended up doing like a half an hour
when i normally do the 20 minute segment
but hassan bought a three million dollar
house which in this capitalist system
even with a welfare state i think is
fine but in a socialist system because
he brought up the word socialism
the house is the means of production the
ability to have a big when you're in the
media you know we have we're in this big
house right now with multiple rooms and
different studios
the house is the means of production
that people have a space to work it's
akin to a factory we've got a bunch of
different computers we've got tons of
computers so the computers are the means
of production this microphone is this
keyboard is that camera is and the house
itself is the factory
so in a socialist system i don't think
poor working-class people the
proletariat would tolerate a three
million dollar mansion i think they'd be
like you are producing web videos by
yourself great you're not exploiting
anybody but that building should be open
to others to do the same thing and when
you are not streaming your camera and
computer should be available to the
public
to use the means of production that you
use
i i think that's what socialist politics
is definitely how pure socialism is goes
wrong well i mean but it is but in a
sense it's not just how it goes wrong
it's the logical conclusion
right i mean it is the logical
conclusion i mean look these are by
definition means of production you are
producing things through these means and
you are generating all of this this
stuff through it and so why should you
not like if you're not going to look at
it through the respect of private
property and ownership well then why
shouldn't this be for the benefit of the
you know quote unquote community i think
a lot about socialism big s and small s
like socialism the government style big
s authoritarianism the big a
authoritarianism is like the government
style then there's authoritarian with a
small like an ad an adjective and how
you can weave socialist small s or
authoritarian small a functions into a
democratically republic system and still
have it function even better than if you
hadn't woven those right
but i guess i guess what frustrates me
at times um and like even with the
conversation we were having before about
left libertarians versus like our school
they call right libertarians i don't
know whatever mises i think rothbard ron
paul libertarians whatever you want to
call that i don't i don't care if you
want to call us right libertarians like
that's that's fine i'm not like offended
by it but
it's like so tell me the the distinction
which i feel like left libertarians
always kind of beat around the bush
because the idea that like well you can
have socialism here or lowercase s
socialism it's like yeah no no one in
our libertarian school is ever denying
that you can't have a a co-op well go
have your co-op there's co-ops all over
the place go have your co-op do
everything you want to the the idea that
you can't buy a
plot of land and turn it into a commune
of course go no one's trying to stop you
from doing that we're libertarians
that's exactly my point right
libertarianism cannot scale past one
community so with
left libertarians i always say hippies
on a farm you know it's like ian's
sitting there and he grew some you know
mangoes or whatever me made bread ian
made bread when i walk in the kitchen
ian goes yo i made bread you want some
he doesn't ask me for an exchange it's
just yeah yeah right right tim you got
the flour i made the bread i made the
bread though so without me you wouldn't
have the bread you'd only have the flour
and then we just openly share like ian
can take the flour whenever he wants
i'll have some of the bread whenever he
makes it what happens though when the
neighbor walks over and walks up and
takes the bread yeah it's like and you
see each layer it gets a little bit more
like maybe that could work if you're
real close with your neighbor but then
what about another neighborhood the guy
from down the street comes and we don't
have any arrangements with him and you
can't just manifest one and so then when
i'm like stop taking my bread and he
says you don't own the bread i'm like
we're going to use we got to go to war
basically a mini war you know so that
that's the idea of a feud left
libertarianism exists in very very small
random pockets there's one very famous
commune of 100 people where it's very
well organized and it's a commune uh
when one person announces they're
leaving they go to their waiting list
and then invite one person hey this
person in two weeks is gone you will
come in we'll teach you the rules sure
everybody's equal we have a farm and it
functions people desperately want to go
there and it exists because they're not
in a system that mandates they give
their stuff to the government they're
allowed to keep it their commune retain
retains the private property well that's
it right so so my point right there is
that basically it but but so my point is
that if even when your say doesn't scale
the only way this is workable is under
our private property system i agree so
you come back to being us so so my point
is that you're just one of us who wants
to live on the communists which is fine
but don't so unless you're if you're
calling in this other thing right right
exactly it doesn't work or it turns into
some other thing and if you're not that
they just explained to me the
distinction that's why that's why i said
as much as i disagree with ron paul a
lot of policies he's always said i'll
leave you alone and i'm like great i can
do my thing can i tell you i was a left
winger before i found ron paul in 2007
and that's when i i he really i found
him in the giuliani moment where he
called giuliani out for the real motives
of terrorism and the evils of the u.s
empire and i was like that's the
greatest thing i've ever seen and then i
started reading all of his books and
reading a bunch of other libertarians
and i i was converted uh after looking
at first when i was starting to read it
i was like i gotta read this libertarian
stuff to find out what's wrong with it
like i was gonna read it to like
disprove it and then along the way
somewhere i just got converted like they
were better
but my thing with that what you just
said is why i really thought in my uh
silly naive young mind that i was going
to be able to convert a bunch of
leftists because i go this is there's
such a good pitch to the left here is
what i thought because i go look if you
embrace libertarianism and reducing the
government like drastically reducing the
size and scope of government then look
you end immediately all the evil things
that you hate now this is during the
bush administration so like wars you
know they were really against the wars
that time and the war on drugs and
police brutality and all this stuff that
the leftists really hate and look all
that other stuff that you guys love like
welfare and taking care of poor people
and any type of this tough stuff like
socialism i go you can have all of that
you just have to do it voluntarily you
know like so you can have that you guys
just got to come together in your own
voluntary community and then you can do
all of this so isn't this the perfect
compromise pitch to the leftist you can
you can get rid of all the things you
hate and have all the things you love
you just have to come do it voluntarily
and um
yeah that that was not as well received
as i thought and i have actually
persuaded a lot more right-wingers than
left-wingers which i was surprised by
they're mostly authoritarians who just
want stuff yeah so my view is always
like this you know ronnie they want it
quickly right ron paul comes out and he
says i believe we got to do this thing
and that thing and this thing and i'm
like i don't agree with those things and
then he goes and if i was elected i'd
leave you alone so you can do your own
thing i'd like you got me yeah
i'm gonna have my little farm and i'm
gonna have my hippie friends and we're
gonna be left alone dude ron paul said
this once and i think it was in god i
can't remember if it was the 28 20 2008
or the the 2012 campaign but he said if
he he he said this thing where he was
like basically like oh there's all this
excitement he has like tens of thousands
of people around him and he was like so
now people are asking what's going on
here you know like what do you stand for
and he said my foreign policy he goes i
would describe my foreign policy as the
following he said
i don't want to run the world
i don't know how to run the world the
constitution doesn't give me the
authority to run the world we ought to
mind our own business and i would
describe my domestic policy as the
following
i don't want to run your life
i don't know how to run your life the
constitution doesn't give me the
authority to run your life we ought to
respect individual liberty and i always
thought that was just the most powerful
honest and humble political message i'd
ever heard that really the message is
that anyone who's telling you they want
to run the world or want to run your
life first off does not have any moral
or legal authority to do so and and also
just doesn't know how to do it
the only honest thing was to admit that
you don't we have a good one see
hennessy says dave serious question if
you were to be president and taiwan was
attacked would you honor our agreements
to assist
well what do you even mean by assist in
taiwan look man we gotta like
i hope taiwan is not attacked and i root
for freedom of people everywhere but we
really gotta get over this empire
mentality that we can do something about
like what do you want to do you explain
to me the logistics of what are you
going to get military in there and start
fighting a hot war with with a
nuclear-armed power like china and then
what we're going to like start just
blowing up cities all across the world
and then still not be able to stop them
from taking taiwan i mean like at a
certain point americans got to like take
a slice of humble pie and recognize that
look we just we just lost to the taliban
in a 20-year war okay you think we're
going to take on the chinese on their
territory how about there's one problem
that ever exists that's just not our
battle to fight i root for them i do not
want to see them fall to china i don't
like the government of china they are a
creepy authoritarian
quasi-communist quasi-fascist government
but
what do you think we're gonna do man
like what you you actually think like
yeah like you want to go to a nuclear
war and lose what
seoul and tokyo and maybe la and then
we'll will blast three of their cities
and then after all of that we still
won't be able to get the forces in to
save taiwan where has sorry for us yeah
really world war ii yeah it was a a
stunning success only 60 million
you know you want another one of those
all right jesse meek says the thing i
like most about shim cast is the diverse
people you bring together amazing
discussions please give a shout out and
consideration to a few other amazing
tubers liberty doll guns and gadgets
good patriot philosopher and patriot
nurse amazing people all i would also
like to shout out seamus coughlin the
host of shim cast who hasn't been with
us for a week he quit the show we took
it over
we did a joke when sheamus was here oh i
love sheamus uh freedom tunes yeah he's
the best we changed the image to say
shim cass instead of tim cast okay and
then he introduced the show it was funny
seymour max says tim i've lost track of
how many times you've mentioned the
mises caucus in your videos i think it's
like seven
this is much needed go watch the fight
it's just 56.
i think i was just keeping track the
whole time it was successful just
watching it
just like uh the fight has just begun a
mises documentary is that what it's
called that's it yeah they just put it
out it was a documentary of like the
struggle of the mises caucus versus the
other lp people in pennsylvania it's
very inside baseball for people who are
like into the lp first of all shout out
to doc who who did the super chat um but
yeah it's a documentary put out like he
said it's a little bit more inside
baseball but it gives you an idea of
uh what we're facing inside the party in
order to red pill the party and and
you know the tricks that are being
pulled and all that kind of thing so if
you want to get kind of an insider view
of the kind of things that we're dealing
with that's a good thing and if you like
if you if you like what you're hearing
in this conversation
go to takehumanaction.com and help us
you know help you take care of
inaction.com is the place to go and
understand what we're doing just to be
clear is that we're bringing the liberty
movement into the libertarian party
we're bringing that real ron paul
libertarian energy that's serious and
facing the about you know the real
issues facing the country and we are
also in the process
dewokifying an institution for perhaps
the first time in history i'm not sure
there's ever been an institution that
went woke and then has been de-occupied
and we're about to do that yeah shaking
off progressivism i think might be
historic and also uh angela mcardle for
chair of the libertarian party that's
coming up this next year right when's
the convention michael it's uh may it's
labor day weekend so may of 22 may of
2022 angela mcardle she's awesome she's
going to be the next chair of the
libertarian party and uh yeah check her
out we got some critics of hassan
pointing out they say hassan uh ultranat
says hassan leaves for hours and lets
others videos go red dragon says hassan
is on camera for 10 hours but only talks
for one he's influenced jxe is right
about everything hassan watches videos
and occasionally says yeah huh okay well
there you go
i i watched that i could do a little bit
more i just don't understand why would
you even want to do that
it's a hot topic because you build up a
big stream the longer you stream the
more people come the more this is he's
on um what's the thing twitch twitch the
video game stuff right yeah well they
have just chatting now okay all right
man i bet you thought only fans was only
for porn
not anymore bro
i think even if you don't think he's
doing that much like
he's successful and he figured it out
yeah and i think you're allowed to be
progressive and leftist and still be
rich the issue i suppose is like if he
was arguing that people shouldn't be
allowed to be rich at all
which i don't think he does all right
fair enough yeah look i think you know
we can argue why his ideas his ideas are
bad but i think being like oh you bought
a house it's like come on man you're not
you're not winning an argument by ad
hominem you know what i mean yeah no i
but i do think and even leaving hassan
aside or whatever but i do think there
is something to be said for like say
bernie sanders you know when he becomes
a millionaire and then like you know
like itemizes his deductions to pay your
own taxes
yeah like there is something about that
words like dude you were you just spent
30 years attacking millionaires saying
they should pay 70 taxes you're paying
like whatever it ended up being like 15
18
and then giving like two or three
percent to charity
you if you really believe that i i don't
think it's too much to say lead by
example and say okay look i'm only
paying 20 in tax but i'm going to give
another you know 40 away to charity
because i really believe that no one
needs this much money and that then i
then i would at least i'd still disagree
with you but i'd at least like take what
you're saying seriously and be like hey
that guy's got some real principles when
you got two or three houses and you're
making millions of dollars ragging on
the rich that's like yeah
yeah
yeah
i just don't like hypocrisy but i do
like capitalism and i like success so i
don't hate him for the success
and that's the funny thing the people
who are ragging on them for being rich
are left not right the writer like oh
wow congratulations on being rich
why are you rich
the thing i said is like if what should
he just keep his wealth a secret should
he not buy anything with all the money
he's got he's probably making a couple
mil per year i think to change a society
you need to be super rich like if you
look at the american founding fathers
they were super rich and like i've lived
my whole life in this like this pious or
whatever like charitable state where i
don't want to get rich because i don't
like this system and i don't want to
involve myself in it but it's ridiculous
you want to be like elon musk jeff bezos
controlling swaths of industry then you
can implement your political change but
well it's about yeah the work you do and
what you build up that gets you to the
point where you have control over
systems
that's true too because if i had like
600 billion dollars it'd be different
than owning amazon yeah well look it all
it all depends on exactly what you're
after i mean all of these things are
kind of like you know they're different
forms of power
um and they're different forms of of
influence but if you you know um being
you can be very very wealthy and and use
that in certain ways you can be somebody
who's very respected and admired and use
that in certain ways you can also just
be a really great father or friend or
son or that and that can make a big
difference in an individual's life so
there's all different ways to kind of
like shape the world around you but yeah
there's no question that like very very
rich people have a disproportionate
amount of influence that's a good point
though about the attention economy and
the value of people knowing who you are
and respecting you because oh yeah
you still need some modicum of of broad
support or public support because like
look at bloomberg like look at all that
money that he threw at his election and
got land yeah that's a that's a very
good point that's a very good point
there's something there are there are um
things that are maybe um like
unmeasurable commodities in a sense like
uh like respect you know what i mean
that like there's not everyone can buy
like michael bloomberg has a lot more
money than ron paul does but i'll tell
you ron paul like he's not spoken of the
way that ron paul is amongst people who
really admire him and you know so just
the same way that freedom and
responsibility are axiomatically the
same thing power and competence and
responsibility are axiomatically the
same thing well and i think you could
argue well yeah yeah actually they
should be i should say they should be
yeah right because that's perhaps things
things really start to collapse when
they're not uh axiomatically linked
right so when people have
don't have yes exactly
we've got a leg horn chicken that lays
double yolk eggs
and so we we i saw your chickens i think
i know which one it is it's the little
one no way the little one yeah oh that
is not who i was going to go with yeah
it's crazy because the eggs are massive
and they're double up so i'm thinking
like we want this one to have babies
right because we like this because when
you see something being done right so
now i'm thinking about it is the paul
family propagating because we need more
little ron paul and if not they've been
a lot of robots and download ron paul's
brain into rand is pretty incredible i
mean there will never be another ron
paul ron is wrong that's true miranda's
and i i will say i was playing different
games yeah well look i was i was very
disappointed in um rand paul's 2016
campaign and i like heartbroken about it
i i really had high hopes for him and he
just didn't continue the ron paul thing
but i also do think now in hindsight
looking back at it that it was a little
bit unfair like i was comparing him to
who like my greatest hero ever was yeah
just because he's his kid and now if i
never knew about who ron paul was and
you asked me about rand paul i'd go i
don't know he's just the best senator
ever and like so so right you know what
i mean it's like to be fair and and he
really has look man through this whole
look he was great on so many different
things like the brennan filibuster and a
bunch of other things but through this
whole kobe hey filibuster yeah yeah
that's right he was great on that but
through this whole cobot thing he's just
been nothing short of heroic i mean what
he's gotten fouchy on tape saying just
backing him into these corners and
getting him it's like almost the perfect
trap where he gets fouchy to say these
things the next day all the blue checks
are like rand paul owned two weeks later
the cdc agrees with ryan paul you know
like it's just perfect and i we all owe
him
definitely absolutely we uh we'll do one
more one more uh so smash that like
button this one this one's very
important and press the like button yeah
yeah sorry
really take your time you you you must
we we command you i'm just kidding it's
not enough to passively watch this video
you must actively smash that like button
thank you joe all right angela mcardle
says mike how do people become delegates
for the libertarian national convention
oh that's angela mccartney that is our
future chair
being uh at work on that stream that's
awesome interesting question angela
never thought of that
so what people need to do is you need to
join the libertarian party but what's
what's more important than joining the
libertarian party is joining your state
libertarian party so if you live in
michigan you need to join the
libertarian party of michigan
pennsylvania the libertarian party of
pennsylvania
um and then there's also your county
level parties so you want to get active
there and now it differs state by state
but ultimately you want to join your
state party you want to show up to your
uh state party convention whenever that
might be and get elected but this is why
you got to go to takehumanaction.com
because if you go to that we have 230
organizers around the country and and if
you
sign up on the email list on there not
only do you join our email list but you
get you get hooked up with our
organizers we'll bring you in there's a
whole network they can help you become a
delegate
right on there you go perfect and that's
how you're going to get everybody to
start taking over the party and changing
the world or whatever it is yeah come on
look dude change of town yes even i know
i know you've said it like a bunch
before and it's part of the reason and i
understand we're all in this in this
position of like look man like i don't
know what the best option is to do this
or that but you've talked about like
look the democrats are a nightmare
ninety percent of the republicans are a
nightmare maybe there's a few good ones
here or there
the libertarians who run as republicans
is their only way in that well well
right but then you just look at this and
you go man i don't care what's happened
over the last 16 months or even the last
20 years this is the united states of
america and we deserve better than that
these two parties have basically
committed in effect treason against the
american people they have sold us out
for their own interests many times
foreign interests okay
in effect they've committed treason
against their own people what are we
supposed to do keep choosing between
these two parties on which type of of
you know treason we want to deal with
why the american people the united
states of america deserves better than
that let's give it to you when we talk
about press secretary michael malus
we're talking about in a presidential
campaign but i'd like you to i'd like
you to imagine an actual press secretary
in an administration walking up to the
podium in the white house and then
calling on journalists and schooling
them
better like it's kaylee mckennedy times
100. you know what i mean just mocking
them ruthlessly and then giving them a
history lesson i actually have a can you
imagine how good michael malice's press
secretary will be i have to do this just
for him i have another i have another
link on the malice tip actually
malice at one point said that if the
party would do it that he would take the
keys to the twitter if the party would
do it the party ain't gonna do it but if
you wanna if you wanna make it well you
can
you know like me and you we're saying we
gotta put public pressure on these these
points and the mandates you can go to
malice for lptwitter.com and sign the
petition and then we can go and say hey
there's ten thousand people it's like
half the party malice for lp twitter
yeah.com
no no that's that is legit like getting
an actual uh getting someone of that
talent to run the twitter account would
be pr gold make sure it says run by
michael malus in the description
go to his personal page too and know
what's going on and i also wanted to add
another point about like what you were
saying about with the republican party
in 2012 when ron was running there was
rasmussen polls showing that the only
republican candidate that was winning in
the polls against obama was ron paul
yeah that's right i remember that and
and
they went with mitt romney
they went with mitt romney so i yeah i
mean listen i'm not saying i understand
it's 2021 it's not 2020. it's not 2012
and i got it like move on from that but
for for all the right wingers who
understandably are just furious at
everything that the left wing has done
to the country you do have to understand
that you had an option in 2012 to vote
for
literally thomas jefferson a better
version of thomas jefferson and ron paul
and you chose mitt freaking romney so
i mean like like grapple with that if
now if you're young if you're like 20
and you didn't vote in that election
okay i'll let you off the hook but if
you are a right winger who supported
mitt romney over ron paul then you just
like
you don't get to complain about anything
you had your chance forget the politics
for a second we've spent a lot of time
talking about how this whole thing is a
cultural battle that's manifesting
itself through politics right so and we
also talked about how the the we're
gonna have to capture the counterculture
forget the politics you're telling me
the republican party is that going to be
the counterculture begin their ass
kicked culturally for 60 years yeah you
know right so like i think in some ways
i think because it's a cultural battle
is why we have to go through the lp
because we can actually build our own
culture build our own now to build our
own stories whereas the republican party
culturally is hated by half the country
that's right no that that's true that's
true even as bad as the democrats are
you look at the polling like i go to
civics
the republicans are disfavorable more
you know why because mitch mcconnell no
no because republicans are sick of them
yeah so with the democrats it's
republicans and independents who are
like the democrats are like yeah the
republican party is republicans
independents being like
is this what we get no you're absolutely
right all right we'll do this is the
last one angela mcardle again saying i
will give malice those keys yeah
thank you angela that's so if angela is
chair of the party then she has the
authority to give him the keys so
everybody heard it right there you want
michael malus to to have the keys to the
the libertarian twitter handle all you
got to do is get angela mcardle voted in
as uh uh get her elected as the chair of
the party if you want to understand why
if you're not familiar we've had michael
on the show several times you got to
follow him on twitter and then you'll
start to bask in the glory that is the
perfect trolling of twitter and
the the just
it's it's it's glorious watching him go
after these journalists and and all that
good stuff he's a brilliant writer too a
brilliant writer that's was born in the
soviet union and saw like governments
gone too far from a very early age so
when he talks about anarchy he's really
doing it from an uh an erudite place and
he's he's also uh he's he's an excellent
writer not just in the fact that he's
like a super smart guy and he knows a
lot about history and makes really good
arguments but just his his like prose
and his technical writing is just very
enjoyable to read it's something i
really admire as a very as a very crappy
writer i really admire very good writers
and um he's an excellent writer he's got
great range because yeah you can go on
twitter and and see and laugh at him
trolling people and it's just it's
glorious but then you can like watch say
for example the the lex friedman
interview and he's talking about his
what his grandma had to go through yeah
and started crying
he's got a like incredible range and all
of that stuff and like i said a great
writer by the way if i ever write a book
and it's well written michael malus
wrote that book just saying no i did not
write on that one i did not all right
everybody it's been a blast hanging out
with all of you on friday night smash
that like button subscribe to
timcast.com
we've got uh the vlog is picking up
steam so we actually had a midweek
episode we went to a rock store and
bought crazy fossils and giant quartz
crystals it was a lot of fun so go to
youtube.comcastcastle you know why we're
doing the vlog because we've talked
about how we can't just keep making
content that is like oh the news is bad
the news is bad so we were like let's
make something good and fun with
chickens and the dogs running around in
the trampolines we're having a good time
riding motorcycles just trying to make
something that can like lift your
spirits and show you some pretty trees
and stuff and then we got a couple more
shows so we're doing some um rehearsals
and screenings for the new mystery show
we got a dnd show we're working on where
it's going to be a whole lot of fun
dungeons dragons again to make culture
to inspire people to make it so that
people aren't just watching nothing but
negativity we're we're taking that
revenue from all of you guys members and
we're putting it right back into making
more and more stuff so that you can
watch it and enjoy it so thanks for all
of that you can follow us at tim cast
tim cast irl basically everywhere you
can follow me at tim cast do you guys
want to shout out social medias oh yeah
at comicdavesmith on twitter uh the
problem dave smith on instagram
and uh part of the problem is my podcast
uh so go check that out
so for me it's i'm not the biggest
twitter user but uh mises at missy's
chair on twitter uh we also got the the
facebook group libertarian party macy's
caucus and then the big thing is join
that email list get in touch with your
organizers take humanaction.com
and uh help us decentralize the state
right on i'm also uh that's awesome
that's a good one decentralized uh hey
um my name is ian crossland and you can
follow me in crossland.net i i just want
to show you this is quartz crystal this
is one of the pieces that tim procured
at the uh at the gem store
we got quartz because it's um this
thing's incredible what's it called
pizzo electric or something like yeah
electric it means that when it vibrates
it produces an electrical charge really
yeah yeah that's how the watches work
they just use the quartz it's going to
be really yeah it'll be like the future
of uh electrical generation a lot of
ways is piezoelectricity when you can
tap into the vibration of the uh the
vacuum itself we're going to get back to
how we made the pyramids finally oh yeah
there might be something to that they
were giant batteries yeah i don't know
about that they're just it's what people
could figure out how to build let's
stack up a bunch of rocks they put gold
on the very top which is a super
conductor
oh okay interesting
i do find all of that stuff very
interesting right on if you're going to
have a couple hours to go deeper into
that
[Laughter]
in the new show definitely right that
would be fun yeah super awesome i'm also
here thank you guys all so much for
tuning in to the first episode of the
michael malus fan hour irl i hope that
you guys will tune in on monday i'm not
sure how much of a michael mouse fan
hour irl it will be that day but it's
going to be awesome then as well you
guys may please follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids because i am approaching
sourpatch kids and followers i'm excited
about that
and uh
we got steve bannon next tuesday yeah so
we wanted to follow up because uh he
made some predictions about schools and
what the parents were going to do
and i think he was correct he said the
parents were going to flip out so we're
going to follow up with that and then
obviously follow up with some other you
know uh political issues but that's
going to be in the members podcast
because youtube would ban us if we
talked about those issues but uh you
know we'll we'll we'll see how it rolls
out and uh thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all then bye guys
you